ocean standing in the name of my
honorable and right honorable friends Mr
Deputy speaker we've called this debate
to provide the house with the right that
it should have to make the decision on
whether fracking should be allowed to
restart across our country the business
secretary made clear last week that he
will not give the house a binding vote
on the principle of the fracking ban
despite them overturning their Manifesto
promise to keep the ban in place despite
the concern on all sides of this house
despite the concerns of the public if
our motion is passed it will mean that
on the 29th of November the house would
debate a fracking bill in six weeks time
we have done this today because we know
what would have happened if we had a
simple motion on fracking in the
opposition day the government would
simply have abstained and ignored the
vote as they have in votes on the
windfall tax fire and rehire the cut to
Universal Credit and no doubt they'll
try and do so with the motion that was
just passed Mr Deputy speaker this is
about faith in politics the government
is seeking to break its Manifesto
promise without even getting the consent
of this house today we give all members
a chance to make this crucial decision
on fracking now let me go through the
substantive arguments against fracking
there are four key questions for the
house on the country will it make a
difference to the price of energy the
answer is no is there categorical
evidence that it is safe the answer is
no is it consistent with any remotely
serious response to the climate crisis
the answer is no and crucially do people
want it the answer is no
I will give way here we also accept
there's another question to be asked
namely since we required to have gas to
at least 2050 one trillion pounds worth
of gas to be imported
well a vital question is where are we
going to get that glass from
I do say to him we can have a debate
about North Sea oil and gas for example
fracking is a wholly different category
it is dangerous it is expensive and it
is not supported by the public now first
price for let me just make a bit more
Pro I will give way up
Uncle gentleman he knows that I like
better colleagues are not in favor of
fracking and would like us to maintain a
Manifesto uh commitment but he also
knows that by playing party political
games this afternoon there is no way
that we could vote for his motion is he
more interested in genuinely opposing
fracking or is he actually more
interested in playing party political
games and trying to score points on this
really important issue of great
importance to our constituents I'm glad
I'm glad we've got a member on the
opposite side who wants to uphold their
Manifesto It's a refreshing change I
have to say Mr Deputy speaker but here's
the thing he should be directing his
point to the right honorable gentleman
the Secretary of State he was explicitly
asked on the radio last week will he
give the house a binding vote on this
issue and I think the case for it is
massively strengthened by the fact that
the party opposite is breaking its
manifest I promise he said no and we are
fosting this debate because it is the
only way we can give the house a binding
vote on this issue I want to talk about
I want to talk I will in a moment but
let me let me make some progress I want
to talk about price first of all I know
he's not exactly flavor of the month but
the recently departed Chancellor of
these Checkers said this in February
even if we lifted the fracking
moratorium tomorrow no amount of shale
gas from hundreds of Wells dotted across
rural England would be enough to lower
the European price private companies are
not going to sell the Shale gas they
produce to UK consumers below the market
price they are not Charities after all
the climate change committee misstep
speaker says the same even the founder
of quadrilla Chris Cornelius says even
if the UK were to generate significant
gas we are not likely to see lower gas
prices any more than living next to a
farm would mean paying less for milk and
the reason I will in a moment and the
reason and the reason is that prices are
set in the European market and the best
evidence from the British Geological
Survey says that fracking can meet less
than one percent of European gas demand
and even that I will in a moment and
even that in a number of years time
hence it will make no difference to
price no amount from of hand waving from
the secretary of state will change that
fact I give away the honorable lady uh
giving way is it not true that he said
at the labor party conference on the
24th of September 2013 that of course
there could be a role for fracking if it
can meet safety concerns well I'm very
glad she's done her research about what
I said on the 24th of September 2013
because so have I this is what I did
this
is
this is this is what I I think she
should listen this is what I said I
believe when George Osborne says
fracking is a Panacea he is totally
misguided the notion it can solve
Britain's energy problems is just
nonsense and I went on to say it needed
to meet safety concerns and the needs of
local residents since then since then no
I won't since then Mr since then mister
since then Mr Simpson since then Mr
Deputy speaker it's been shown it cannot
meet safety concerns and it cannot meet
the needs of local residents second
second second I want to second second
and I'm not gonna give away second
second I want to come to the question of
whether it is safe as whether it is safe
because the second I want to come to the
question of safety because that has been
the long-standing debate a debate which
we LED in 2013 about fracking now the
conservative Manifesto said we will not
support fracking unless the science
shows categorically it can be done
safely it is very important to go back
to what happened in 2019 and why the
government introduced the moratorium the
then business secretary the member for
Southampton North the South
northamptonshire hardly Mr Deputy
speaker a tofu eating woke Lefty said
this it is clear we cannot rule out
future unacceptable impacts on the local
community now this Deputy speaker is not
surprising she concluded that I wonder
if the right honorable gentleman has
read the official report from the time I
have because I'm a nerd Mr Deputy
speaker and they said and they said they
could not rule out an event of 4.5 on
the Richter Scale having already seen a
2.9 Richter Scale event at Preston new
road I want to tell the house what the
impact of such an event would be by
reading from the report such as scenario
wood and I quote be widely felt there
could be widespread building damage in
the study area with cracked plaster work
affecting approximately 10 percent of
buildings more serious structural damage
or varying degree degrees affecting 5.4
percent of buildings including chimney
failure some damage will be caused to
buildings outside of the study area
Mr Deputy speaker
that is why the government banned
fracking and why they said they would
not restart it unless the British
Geological Survey said it was safe in
the words of the then business secretary
in April of this year
unless the latest scientific evidence
demonstrates that Shale gas extraction
is safe sustainable and of minimal
disturbance to those living and working
nearby the pause in England will remain
in place no ifs no buts and I will
actually make the progress on this point
and in their report published last month
their Geological Survey said they could
not provide that Assurance instead they
said hydraulic fracturing can trigger
earthquakes large enough to cause
structural damage these events were not
predicted in advance of operations so
here is the key point for the hot for
the whole house there certainly is not
the compelling evidence about safety
that the government promised would be
the basis of any lifting of the ban Mr
Deputy speaker this is as clear an
example of a broken Manifesto promise as
you're ever likely to see I give way to
The Honorable gentleman I'm grateful to
the writer of a gentleman and he's
making a compelling case against
fracking with which I fully agree would
he also agree with me that for all of
those potential downsides which he's
referenced there was absolutely no
guarantee that any Shale gas extracted
would be sold
in the National Domestic Market it would
go on it would go to the highest bidder
there could be real downsides for our
communities with no no obvious uplift in
Supply
again someone puts it incredibly well
that is why this is such a nonsense idea
that the government is is coming up with
and so and so the government is not just
breaking a Manifesto promise because no
doubt they're going to say ah yes the
manifesto was before the the Russian
invasion of Ukraine but promise made in
April of this year by by government
ministers and his response his response
Mr Deputy speaker is not to abide by the
promise but to seek to shift the goal
post in his Immortal Words which I hope
MPS will take back to their
constituencies tolerating a higher
degree of risk and disturbance appears
to be us to be in the National interest
I think that could be a description of
the government Mr Deb Mr Deputy speaker
this is a matter of trust how can
communities across this country how
could communities across this country
trust the government which says one
categorical thing in its Manifesto
repeats it in April and then goes back
on its word with no mandate from the
from the British people I have such a
sort of uh fantastic choice I think my
honorable friends giving away he talked
about the government
um putting the ban on because of the
risk of disturbance to local communities
there was a proposal to frack in Marsh
Lane which happens to be in the
neighboring constituency of Northeast
elbertshire and I think the The
Honorable member there is now the
planning Minister perhaps dealing with
fracking the reality is there were going
to be dozens if not hundreds of Lorry
movements a day down rural Lanes this is
what the disturbance can be and lots and
lots of Wells drilled which were going
to despoil the local environment isn't
this the reality of fracking which every
member there or opposite or to think
about if they were prepared to accept in
their local communities I think my
honorable friend puts it uh incredibly
well and I and I do agree with him so
fracking will
yes I will give away he's very kind I'm
grateful in terms of trust he will know
that the government set up this new
consultation to determine what public
consent is would you agree with me that
it is a monstrous waste of time and
money to try to determine something that
doesn't exist there is no local consent
for this the government itself plenty of
them don't actually want it if he really
wants to know what consent is why
doesn't he have a general election The
Honorable lady makes a point very well
and she anticipates I'm the issue I'm
going to come on to shortly so fracking
will not make a difference to Bill's
Miss Deputy speaker we cannot be sure of
its safety and is a disastrous response
to the climate crisis the the decision
the decision I won't give away for the
moment the decision the decision on
fracking and is particularly
environmentally damaging with emissions
from fracking up to 50 higher than from
conventional gas and here is the point
Mr Deputy speaker if every country
follows the lead He suggests of
extracting every last drop of their
fossil fuel reserves global temperatures
to rise to over three degrees Centigrade
smelling catastrophe for our children
and Grand children I have to say this
should be patently obvious to anyone not
least the person in charge of fighting
against the climate crisis I I want to
no I won't I won't give up I want to
make some progress because there are
many people who want to speak I want to
come on I want to come in I want to come
on to Mr Debbie speaker to The crucial
issue of what the public think
I suggest that the business secretary
looked at the surveys conducted by his
own Department 78 of the public support
onshore wind 83 tied on offshore wind 87
solar but just 17 of people support
fracking now suddenly in a sign of
desperation about how grossly unpopular
and unwanted this policy is they say
they want to design a system of local
consent I don't know I'm not going to
give away for the moment I don't know
why he wants further Evidence about what
communities think we already have the
answer from the public fracking is
deeply unpopular and communities don't
want it indeed file Council controlled
by his party at the center of the main
UK experiment in fracking just passed a
unanimous motion saying the ban should
remain and saying he should honor his
Manifesto commitment I I I will I will
give away yeah I'm very grateful to my
right honorable friend he knows how the
planning system works as well as I do
councils can refuse planning permission
they can support their local community
is but those fracking companies have the
ability to appeal that decision to the
planning inspector and he knows public
opinion is not a material planning
consideration for the planning in
Spectrum isn't this just a smoke and
mirrors to get these unpopular proposals
through the Tory benches when everybody
knows the public opinion counts for
nothing my honorable friend is
absolutely right and they and you know
there's there's more sort of weasel
words in relationship local said I think
the uh yes the right The Honorable
gentle has been desperate to get in
I find myself in strange agreement with
many of the arguments being made from
the opposition dispatch box however will
he be clear that the vote that we're
having tonight is not on Banning
fracking but is on a procedural matter
for the House of Commons and will he
square up to the public and be truthful
to the public about what it is that we
are voting on tonight what we are voting
on our proposal to bring in a bill to
ban fracking and the and the and I say
to The Honorable gentleman of whom I
have a large amount of respect I do say
to him we are not going to get a vote on
the principle of fracking because the
business secretary has said that in
terms this is his chance this is I know
he's against fracking this is his chance
to stand up for his constituents and say
no to fracking now I want to I want to
say something more about the issue of
consent uh and and their Amendment and
to and to say something to the house as
a whole to his back benches and it goes
to the honorable gentleman don't fall
for the government's weasel words in
this debate right the the way to stop
fracking is to vote for our motion and
if they do not their constituents will
know they had the chance to stop
fracking and refuse to do so and I have
to say Mr Deputy speaker we now discover
this is not all they'll be voting for
tonight because the genius minds of the
government whips office are now seeking
to turn a vote on this important issue
into a vote of confidence in the current
prime minister Mr Deputy speaker picture
the scene the government whips office
confronted with a vote on fracking one
of the least popular causes in the
country the government falling apart
around them they could decide to retreat
but that will be yet another U-turn they
could concede a vote of this house on
the fracking ban but they would lose and
fracking would be dead and then at the
11th Hour one Galaxy brain says the way
to fall through force it through is to
make it a vote not just on one of the
most unpopular causes in the country
fracking but the most unpopular cause in
the country
the current the current prime minister
you might call it Mr Deputy speaker you
might call it Mr Deputy speaker the Frac
me or Sac mean strategy now now Mr David
this week let me see Deputy speaker
in normal times in normal times such an
idiotic idea would have been dismissed
out of hands but these are not normal
times they see it as their leaky life
raft but I say to the house and I say to
members opposite they all know that the
Prime Minister will be gone in a matter
of weeks if not days if not hours they
know fracking will go with her why
defend the indefensible why not be on
the right side of history and their
constituents just like this government
fracking is a dangerous extreme idea
which the British people do not support
and I appeal to all members of the House
particularly members opposite to today
have the courage of their convictions
today is a day when they can put their
constituents before their party and vote
to give this house the decision on a
fracking ban it's time to consign
fracking to the Dustbin of History
foreign
[Music]
to move the amendment
thank you Mr Deputy speaker and may I
thank the right honorable gentleman for
raising this important topic
concerns about
judge and that is why we will salt on
the system of local consent and provide
clear advice on seismic Misty and safety
before any hydraulic fracturing for
Shale gas takes place we are committed
uh yes of course I'll give way excited
it's been so soon in his speech and I'm
grateful to him my right honorable
friend will be aware of deep concerns in
Sussex about fracking it's their
concerns that I share not least because
our 2019 Manifesto said we will not
support fracking unless the science
shows categorically it is safe which I
don't think it does so can I write
honorable friend assure me that in the
government's consultation paper that
he's just referred to on local consent
they will include an option for local
referenda arranged by local authorities
and overseen by the Electoral Commission
Mr secretary Speaker my right honorable
friend has preempted a couple paragraphs
of my speech because I was going to say
that the consultation should consider
the use of local referendums I think
that is one of the ways in which local
consent could be uh indicated and we
want to ensure that consult consultation
not at the moment consultation considers
the views of regional Mayors and local
authorities as well as the immediate
concerns of those most directly affected
and I also wanted to consider the views
of MPS as well as as I said to my
right-home friend local referendums we
will consult on the mechanism but I can
show I can assure the house that any
process of evidencing local support must
be independent rather than directly by
the companies themselves and if evidence
of the appropriate local support for any
development is insufficient that
development should not proceed local
communities will have a veto so I can
assure my honorable friend the member
for rather Valley that if people in his
constituency do not want fracking they
will not have it once
of course I'll get away to my honorable
friend
I'm very grateful to my
giving away could he just confirm that
clarity's sake that the moratorium will
remain in place
whilst
his process of Confrontation is agreed
and it will remain in place until this
is approved by a positive vote in this
place following a debate in a vote on
the floor of the house and can you also
confirm that the government will indeed
move its Amendment today to a division
if time allows and the circumstances are
created I'm grateful to my honorable
friend and I would like to make it
absolutely clear that we need local
consent before anything happens
um no I let me let me be clear as my
honorable friend from Dorset that once
the consultation on the mechanism for
ascertaining a community's view has been
completed the results will be brought to
the house for approval which I think he
was also asking if the house does not
approve I would just a moment does not
approve fracking could not go ahead even
if the house were to approve a mechanism
local communities would still have to
consent in accordance with the mechanism
so I reiterate local communities will
have a veto and I could wait grateful to
the Secretary of State I want to take
him back to the word unless in our
Manifesto in where we said that uh we
weren't support fracking unless the
science shares categorically can be done
safely will the Secretary of State
confirm that the the sense of that word
is that we would leave we would need a
at the very least a New Rapid evidence
review about safety so would the
Secretary of State commit to that or for
the manifesto on which he and I were
elected on I'm I'm very grateful to my
honorable friend and I think his
suggestion is an eminently sensible one
to have a rapid review of the evidence
and how I not give away with my neighbor
from somersets I thank him for
graciously giving way and aside from the
fact that my right or friend might want
to clarify that actually this is a bit
of a game this debate is not exactly
about fracking if it is about if we are
talking about fracking to the to the
previous points scientific evidence and
data is so critical it's everything we
base our policies on and would he um
agree with me that the data shouldn't
just be about seismic activity but the
effect on water will be critical and I
don't just mean the water that's put
down the drilling space is actually the
effect on the hydrology in future years
and I think it's really critical as a
government that we are seen to be very
serious about the scientific evidence on
this I am grateful to my honorable
friend um on both counts first of all my
honorable friend is right to say that
trying to take control of the order
paper is parliamentary into to weaving
rather than actually the substance of
the debate and actually to take control
of the order paper people need to have
won a majority in the election that is
how our system works and I think I think
the experience that we had in 2017 to
2019 proved how bad it is for Parliament
when the order paper is messed around
with so I think that part was bad on on
her Point regarding water I think my
honorable friend is absolutely spot on
it is one of the keys to how things
could be done safely and we have to be
certain that water both the water used
on site and water that may be nearsights
will mean be safe I think my old friend
from Winchester wanted to intervene and
I would happily give way to him that's
very kind of the Secretary of State I'm
not concerned about the threat that
local percent will go the wrong way in
my constituency because I don't believe
for a minute my constituents would give
consent to fracking in our area but just
further to an intervention
they have from his own side around the
planning inspectorate
secretary says local people will have a
veto over this can he just be clear the
planning of Spectra will not have a veto
over local people yeah
let me be absolutely clear local
communities will have a veto if it does
not get local consent
then and that will be consulted on as to
what local consent form must be but if
it and that could be as um my honorable
friend from Sussex asked uh it may be by
local referendum that's what the
consultation will be about but if local
consent is withheld that is a veto and
it won't be overruled by national
government I'll give way once again
I I'm grateful to the Secretary of State
who In fairness to him is trying to
address the serious concerns that he
knows exists on these benches and I
think many of us are grateful to him for
that but I think I heard him say in
response Mr Deputy speaker to my earlier
intervention but I'd just like him to
clarify which is when he brings back
this local consent process tick box
program
if the house votes against it
the moratorium on fracking by its very
definition
remains in place
can you just confirm that for absolute
code I.E today is not the end of the
matter
my older friend is Right today is not
the end of the matter and that if the
house were not to accept the local
consent mechanism then there would not
be an ability for local communities to
give consent and that would mean the
veto were in place I see my
right-handable friend uh from East
Yorkshire wishes to interview
to my right I'm a fan for giving ways
being very generous isn't the neatest
way of assessing local consent to take
away the right of appeal to a planning
inspector in these matters and so the
decision of the local planning Authority
is to be deemed the expression of local
consent and is the final decision
I'm grateful to my right on friend
that's absolutely the purpose of the
consultation to see what form local
concern ought to take I'll give away my
other friend from Gloucester I'm
grateful to him and it is absolutely
true that the motion brought forward by
the opposition of course does not
reflect what's in our Manifesto because
it calls on the government to introduce
a ban on hydraulic parking followed by
three and a half pages of procedural
stuff which is what it's really about
whereas what our Manifesto says is to
introduce a moratorium the question for
the Secretary of State however is that
in his letter to us he says with time we
will gain more understanding of how we
can best develop this potentially very
substantial UK can I put it to him that
the question is with time we'll gain
more understanding of whether we should
best develop this potential asset does
he agree with it and would you accept
that I'm grateful to my honorable friend
we are not preempting local consent uh
in the letter that I sent out so he is
right I think the time has come for me
to return to my text at least for for a
moment or two
um so um I do understand as we have
discussed the concerns that people have
about the safety safety of hydraulic
fracturing and the extra report by the
Royal Society in the Royal Academy of
engineering from 2012 suggests that
Shale gas extraction can be managed
safely and effectively in the United
Kingdom owing to our high regulatory
standards and many decades experience of
extracting oil and gas both on and
offshore and I would like to go back to
the quotation from the right on the
gentleman From Doncaster North who said
and it was reported in Wales online on
the 25th of 2013 of course there could
be a role for it if it can meet safety
concerns in the needs of local residents
so the right honorable gentleman
actually should be voting against his
own motion because he accepted there
should be a role for it now the
government is absolutely determined to
build our energy security at a time
where Andrew Costa worry for many I can
say that we are starting from a
tolerably good place the United Kingdom
is blessed with a healthy mix of
different sources of energy including a
strong wind resource one of the few
significant oil and gas reserves in in
Europe several gas import Terminals and
a well-managed electricity Network we
have also made strong progress in
building new renewable electricity
generation like offshore wind and a plan
to accelerate this further while also
developing new nuclear capacity however
we cannot escape the fact that we are a
nation with a structural Reliance on gas
even though we will be reducing our
alliance on gas on the way to Net Zero
indeed we may be using just a quarter of
The Gas We Now use by 2050 gas will
remain the essential transition Fuel and
this may have been out of sight and out
of mind for some years maybe we were not
sufficiently prepared but we must not
take our local gas supplies for granted
because this year the energy World
changed Putin's war against Ukraine and
the weaponizing of gas supply to Europe
has cut off a major source of supply to
the European markets that we are
connected to and ignited a global rush
for gas resources so why there is no
immediate threat to UK Supply we cannot
let our domestic production fade away
and end up ever more reliant on Imports
no responsible government would gamble
with the gas supply this is why in the
near term our priority is keeping our
domestic production online the North Sea
transition Authority has launched the
33rd oil and gas licensing round which
is expected to deliver over 100 new
licenses and put more UK gas on the grid
and this is why what we're discussing to
make the most of our Shale gas resources
of course everybody's honorable
gentleman
Mr Deputy speaker I always try to be
helpful in this place the way out of
this dilemma if you like is of course
green hydrogen and I repeat what I said
some days ago in this place there are
Advanced plans in micro City with
Northern Scotland to generate 50
megawatts of of energy and short the dog
up to 300 megawatts I again invite to
imagine this government to come and see
our plans it will be helpful to all
concerns
intervention is indeed helpful I think
green hydrogen is one of the most
exciting Technologies and I'm very
enthusiastic about the opportunities now
I'll give away the honorable gentleman
those are the the ministers share my
amusement at some of the arguments we
made here today that we know we're going
to need gas we know we're going to spend
billions of pounds importing gas from
regimes which we can't depend upon and
we know that we have gas in the north of
England which could generate thousands
of jobs and give us the security of our
own Supply what's not to lag about that
I'm grateful to The Honorable gentleman
who puts his thoughts with um classic
cogency not at the moment the government
remains committed to Net Zero by 2050 it
is how we reach it without putting our
energy security at risk The Honorable
gentleman always wants to intervene on
every point and he always says on this
point so it's hard to believe there
really is on this point
um it makes but but but let me say it
makes no sense to become more aligned
on Shale gas produced overseas indeed
the climate change committee's analysis
notes that while current evidence on the
emission footprint of UK Shale gas and
liquefied gas is not yet definitive
available estimates indicate that
emissions from those Imports could be
higher than those that would arise from
commercial UK Shale gas production by
between 2 and 63 grams of carbon dioxide
per kilowatt hour of gas consumed so
using our own resources is more
environmentally friendly and will help
us to get
um to Net Zero and I will give around
that point to my right honorable friend
anyways making some very valid points
indeed it's not just about domestic gas
supplies and electricity production it's
about the chemical industry most
importantly the fertilizer industry one
of our flaps has already shut down the
other plant is now switching from
natural gas from UK sources to ammonia
brought in from the United States
because they have cheap Shale gas to
enable that engine to keep going if we
count future on fertilizing in food
production in this country is under
great threat I mean I am grateful to my
right home friend who puts it very
clearly it is using our own resources is
environmentally friendly but we have to
make sure there is popular consent for
it and I feel that the British public
would not welcome the disruption and
shortages that would be caused by
Labor's policy of taking gas out of the
network on 2030 and I'll give away the
honorable Gentleman on that point I
thank the secretary step for giving ways
been so generous and given way to where
people particularly on his own side
in my constituency of Weaverville indeed
in Ellesmere port and neston Chester we
had a public inquiry only recently and
our communities rejected Shale
extraction we've rejected that and it
costs hundreds of thousands of pounds
that's local consent why do we again
have to jump through hoops to go through
the same process yeah yeah
um military speaker I think honorable
gentleman should be supporting what I'm
saying he shows the value of local
consent and the reality of it if it it
will not always be given and I'm very
well aware of that so let me move on to
seismic limits because we have been
clear that any future exploration or
development of shale gas will need to
meet rigorous safety and environmental
standards drawing on lessons from around
the world we will make sure hydraulic
fracturing for Shale gas is done safely
last month the British Geological Survey
published its report and this is a
really important way of looking at what
the seismic experience has been and
comparing it to other forms of
production are both of energy but also
other forms of manufacturing industry
and the report makes clear that the
forecasting the occur currents are felt
seismic events remains a scientific
challenge for the geoscience community
however it also makes clear that to
improve our understanding we need more
exploratory sites to gather the
necessary data we do not think
we do not we do
we think this is a sensible thing to
look at and that it will be unwise not
to look at it but it must have Community
Support Mr Deputy speaker I'm almost
coming to an end and lots of people want
to speak I have taken I have taken a
vast number of um interventions
including
including three including three from the
opposition but I will give way to The
Honorable lady
and I would ask him to seriously
consider the two aspects of this
wrecking one is that it is unsafe in a
country like United Kingdom which is a
very small landmass and much population
and it might be safe somewhere where
there's thousands and thousands of miles
of Barry land but not in a country like
ours and secondly it doesn't really want
to see this hydraulic disgusting
applications and buildings across our
beautiful country
I I'm grateful to The Honorable lady and
she is always
um a great contributor to this house and
she is right to raise the issue of
safety which will be fundamental to any
proposal for the extraction of of shale
gas so Mr Deputy speaker the world has
changed and our energy policy needs to
recognize this this government will make
the difficult but necessary decisions to
secure the nation's energy Supply
exploring our potentially substantial
Shale gas reserves is potentially an
important part of this but this must not
be looked at in isolation this is why we
are exploring all avenues available to
us including solar wind and nuclear but
we cannot ignore the importance of local
gas production however Mr Deputy speaker
let me reiterate the commitment and I
reiterate this particularly to my
honorable and right honorable friends
that there is an absolute local consent
lock any process to determine local
consent must be run independently and
this house will vote on any scheme that
we bring forward yeah yeah
the original question was as on the
order paper since when Amendment a has
been proposed as on the order paper the
question is that the original word stand
part of the question Alan Brown
thank you master Deputy speaker Governor
the license in North rocking and the
planning processes evolved um I wasn't
enough for a planning to participate in
this debate but given that the
government is actually effectively made
this uh emotional of confidence in the
government and it's only right that we
participate and then outline the
thoughts SNP and no matter what the
official government line is
um the the chair of the public
administration constitutional Affairs
committee earlier on confirmed that the
Tory government is making this a vote of
coincidence and their own government sir
so that was clear so while I do up was
fracking an SNP government is ruled out
fracking in Scotland introduced an
effective bar no in it and so I do agree
filled with emotion in that respect it's
not for us to impose our our views and
what happens in England but Gathering
that as a vote of confidence in the
government then we'll be voting for the
motion to show that we've got no
confidence in this utter utter shambles
of authority government now we've
already heard interventions from tour
MPS on the The Shadow secretary where
they're saying how they're opposed to
fracking and they want to represent
their views of the constituents who
oppose fracking
but they're going to vote for the
government Amendment they're going to
want to vote against
um the motion so that that makes no
sense if they've got any backbone I
would urge them to vote for a ban and
fracking
thank you I I'm grateful Jim because the
SNP are huge champions of local
democracy and therefore does he accept
that actually if a local Council were to
support the idea of fracking that that
does represent local consent and does he
agree that that should be the crucial
issue involved the support of the local
Council
Archway comes to the point I was going
to make if this is all about local
democracy and actual democracy in itself
why is has government making his MPS
vote in a way they say they don't want
it vote how are we going to trust them
to implement some sort some form a local
democracy when MPS are getting forced
against their will to vote for the
government Amendment
um I'll cover it there and then yeah
because at least he's been honest in a
speech today he has made it quite clear
that the only reason why he's
intervening on what he believes is an
English issue is because this is a vote
of no confidence in the government and
surely surely he he understands
therefore uh why uh this ceases to be a
debate about local democracy where we'll
get our gas from this is all about a bit
of political playing by the opposition
[Applause]
a confidence in the government and we're
the ones making their entities for and
the way they say they don't want it
votes it's not opposition that's playing
games it's that law over there I'll
quickly give way there and then their
nanote progress we'll remember for
giving way
um I was a Lancashire County Council
when this first came to council seven
years ago was rejected then and
overruled by the planning inspector
since then the public don't want it
councils don't want want it you know his
own back benches don't want it and in
fact I believe the leader of the
Secretary of State's own Council doesn't
want it ministers also don't want to
apart from in their own backyard
um who actually wants fracking so I
can't think of anybody
um it's a good question and that's more
one for a secretary
um to advance it quite clear the the new
uh these secretary is in favor of it and
he's imposing as well in the rest of his
party real quickly give it and then move
on
fracking and if they want to win the
hearts and Minds the way to do it isn't
by political games and stunts like this
there is no way that we can support the
oppositions
if they want to be serious about
franking let's have a serious debate on
fracking
[Applause]
when the government brings forward that
motion we will be able to vote whether
we support fracking or not the way to do
it is not to hijack the order paper and
play political games
I've got a new strong remember if she
votes for the amendment she's vote for
the principal fracking no matter how she
dresses
Instagram
The Honorable gentleman said that anyone
who votes with the government amendment
is voting for fracking that is not
correct as he and as you know Mr Deputy
speaker a vote for the government
amendment is to vote for the Secretary
of State to bring back a definition of
local consent for this house to vote on
before any fracking can conceivably move
forward would it be possible for you sir
from the chair to advise The Honorable
gentleman of what the truth of the
matter is
all right let's hope there's no more
devices like that that clearly isn't a
point of order for the chair but he's
made his view known and it is on the
record
if we go back to local consent now the
the government motion talks about
Consulting Regional Mayors local
authorities and parishes which is quite
a vague concept and again kind of opens
up to cronyism and and platco
machinations although I do welcome the
sentiment is now talking about local
referenda it's good to know that that's
where the government now believes in the
principles they were referendums for
people to exercise our Democratic right
and I look forward foreign
government's Newfound enthusiasm for
sale gas of course isn't actually a base
incredible evidence now they they might
the put forward arguments will increase
in energy security and
um it's also required because the legal
Russian invasion of Ukraine and they
need to move away and from Reliance in
Russian oil and gas Imports but really
they've arrived at a switch into a
problem it doesn't exist it's quite
clear the UK already had a minimum uh
relying foreign
guys Imports are coming from Russia and
if the argument is there or reduce
prices then that's quite clearly not
true either it was a former B secretary
now former Chancellor that might
admitted that any
any Shale gas would be an international
related commodity that goes in the
international market and the Traders
will determine prices so the only way
that won't happen is unless there's
another Damascus conversion in the the
government's plan in some sort of
nationalized Energy company or fracture
Shale gas and control throw that and put
that in a domestic Market or in prices
because otherwise it's all about
International Market
but Mr Deputy speaker the harsh truth is
is as well with the fact there isn't
even enough for my evidence of what
reserves are available in the basins and
they can be extracted so without that
knowledge any talk of increasing energy
security and reducing Imports in the
future is that is just Pure Fantasy at
this stage
and that also means any tour of jobs in
booster local economies it means
completely speculative and again there's
no evidence when uh
I thank the member for uh giving way we
are a country fortunate enough to house
massive potential for development and
harnessing of renewable energy does the
member agree that in resorting to
fracking the government is essentially
admitting that he has no interest in
developing the skills infrastructure
jobs or Industries necessary for a green
Industrial Revolution in this country
energy Revolution that's happened in
Scotland but of course for going forward
for Scotland to fully Embrace that
potential we clearly need the powers and
opinions I need to get away from these
decision makers over there you know
quickly
by Northern assembly colleagues were
able to temporarily prevent fracking in
Northern Ireland by Banning PDR rights
does the member share my concern
um that the prime minister is taking
advantage of the cost of living crisis
and this coupled with the removal of
retained EU law risks environmental
degradation across these islands and
does nothing to sustainably manage the
climate crisis or the energy crisis
is already said that they're trying to
present a solution to a problem that
doesn't exist it's problems that they're
using to further their arguments and
agree wholehearted water and the Finland
intervention
um can I simply point out that he may
know that satellite data for the United
States shows that fugitive emissions of
methane namely the amount of methane
which is leaked uh from fracking is is a
five percent and given that methane is
80 times worse than CO2 for global
warming that makes fracking worse than
coal so how can anybody who's serious
about Net Zero support fracking think of
that intervention it certainly makes a
point very well and it you know it's
something we need to take nice and solve
and again you have to doubt as
Government will say we're committed to
next year will be 2050 we have to do
have to wonder you know how serious are
they about that and they know 2050 is a
while away that's future governments
away so they can do what they want to
now and pretend that are still in favor
of uh abiding with an extra commitment
now Mr David speaker even if you accept
some of the government arguments there's
also then the reality that exploration
the appraisal phases of of a
Frankenstein is somewhere in order of 35
years so it's not even therefore
possible that fracking can produce any
sort of quick fix solution to the
problems that they think are trying to
solve
and Mr Dave speaker of the Tory
government are so worried about people's
energy bills then I have to ask why did
they do a screaming U-turn in the
so-called energy price guarantee this
week the Prime Minister had told us
previously she she was going to prevent
household energy bills Rising during the
storms from six thousand pounds so
presumably the UK government now believe
unfortunately for the majority of
households in the UK that at some point
they might rise as high as six thousand
pounds post April 2023 when they're
scrapping their energy price guaranteed
and even if we don't think the bills
will go that high it's certainly abuses
estimates in Energy prices paper was
about 4 400 in papers this week we're
speculating now at least average bills
could easily have five thousand pounds
so even if the government does bring
forward measures that they say will
protect the most vulnerable bows going
up to that price are allied with their
record inflation is still going to cause
misery for millions and millions of
people and of course such as households
had already seen mortgage rates mortgage
costs increase directly as a consequence
of the prime minister's ideological
money budget
so already a bad decisions as
governments made also already affecting
um household expenditure and obviously
um this is not not this a solution to it
and if you look at and if you look at
fuel poverty National energy action that
estimated even under the current support
scheme with average household bills
estimated with two and a half thousand
pounds then there's going to be 6.7
million households and fuel poverty
and if obviously if those gotten way way
higher than that then we're looking at
literally millions more in fuel poverty
and Mr David speaker
um add constituency even a year and a
half ago when the average price car or
the police car was seen that Bells set
an average of 1100 pounds they were
struggling then and someone fuel poverty
so when we were looking at bows going up
much much more and they're going to
there's going to be a misery for many so
fracking does nothing to help them in
the here and now in order to government
to start thinking about the support
we're going to have to do to bring
household energy bills down for people
and then and they're not feeling other
measures that should be taken Energy
Efficiency installation they need to
massively increase their commitment to
um upgrading homes to the Target of EPC
band C
engine efficiency installation clearly
reduces energy demand reduces a Reliance
on gas anyway for energy generation
brings and it brings down household bows
and it creates jobs
and the past are looking at energy
security it's not that long ago that the
UK government blocked the development
onshore wind six years of unsure wind
development and that that was blocked
Governor onshore wind as the cheapest
form of energy generation then it's
quite clear arguably they've added costs
to Consumers bills by walking on Shore
wind and again that
that's an electric generation that could
have been made in the UK reducing an
alliance in gas and reducing our lines
on Imports and why was onshore wind
development banned well that was because
there was some loud story about benchers
who were against wind turbines and they
they used that and some voices in the
community
um to argue that uh local consent was
not there for the provision of wind
turbines of course that that was that
was just using a few people to distort
local democracy and it was actually
local demo democracy in Reverse Mr
Deputy speaker because by uh overturned
and onshore wind right across the UK
that was imposing the the view of a few
people in the shires in the rest of the
UK making energy more expensive for the
rest of us
together
and very preferred
the main reason why people were opposed
to unsure wind was because onshore wind
is extremely land intensive and the area
that you take up for 10 fracking pads
would require
725 times more land for windmills which
of course is a plot on the landscape
intervention and proven who areas in the
whole climate change denial aspect and I
think I think most people uh well it's
actually studies show time and time
again studies in service so people are
in favor of unsure wind so and and we
know people are against fracking so his
arguments completely at odds with what
the public thinks and probably about his
own constituents think now on energy
security and further reducing Airline
Zone gas
um the government needs to bring forward
the pricing mechanism for pump storage
Hydro that's one way to meet a peak
dispatchable energy aim to Peak demand
um an SSC I've already all the
permissions in place we've got the
funding there to be able to build the
quarter glass scheme and the highlands
all it is needed is a funding mechanism
now it's predecessor actually said at
the base committee and everything
session that hadn't agreed a price
mechanism wasn't doing anything on it
because it was a predominantly Sportage
technology so it urged the new secretary
to go to go over that mindset and
realize that pump storage hydros for the
good of the grid and it's for the good
of the UK as a whole
of course the bit of the jigsaw this
would be helpful to both the Scottish
government and the UK government is
floating offshore wind production we
have the skills in Scotland in all parts
of fabrication we've got some of the
mightiest all platforms ever built so
surely that is the way forward and
finally to repeat my point again
generating the electricity out to sea to
be taken in and leads to the generation
of green hydrogen
um
let's report my land a landfall strategy
which actually has Fates that Scotland
could have 385 000 jobs created in the
future with a um by developing a green
hydrogen strategy and sell out certainly
benefit has has conceptions here now
I've been up to reporting Ag and um it's
fantastic to see what their plans are
for for the future
damn
Mr Deputy speaker is quite clear then
there's so much more The Government Can
Do fracking is not required and it's not
the actual answer and going forward
there are just people with energy bills
it certainly won't do anything to help
transition to Net Zero and when we know
it's opposed and by the majority of the
public and it seems as just a few people
in this government that's trying to
force farewell in the rest of Parliament
and possibly on these communities who
area
um I Thank The Honorable gentleman for
giving way
um The Honorable the right honorable
member for Northeast Somerset has
brought to the house a proposal now
there's clearly disagreement
um on all over the house on that issue
but at least the honorable member is
opening up for an honest debate on a
very important matter and what I would
like are the The Honorable member has
made a number of criticisms against the
general energy policy of this government
and what I'd like to know is how the SNP
are going to balance out energy security
given that they are actually saying they
oppose nuclear they oppose nuclear and
oil exploration and gas exploration well
considering Scotland's already an
exporter of oil and gas
um the equivalent of our domestic
electricity consumption is already
generated effectively renewable energy
we export electricity
so I think it's quite clear that in
terms of energy Scotland has been
standing its own three feet and actually
it's time we're able to realize the
benefits from being such an energy rich
country because right now it seems to me
the broad shoulders of the UK are
preventing us realizing the benefits
that we should have Mr W speaker this is
the contact conclusion the SNP have
introduced her a ban on fracking or not
uh issue any fracking licenses in
Scotland I would like like to think that
the UK government will respect that
aspect of the Devolution settlement and
not trying overturn we're doing in
Scotland because if they do they'll add
a further few percentage points of those
that believe Independence is the future
for Scotland
oh
um I've already indicated that it's a
six minute limit but because of the
pressure of time and I want to be fair
to everybody it'll be six minutes for Mr
Menzies and Barbara Keely and then it
drops immediately to four minutes so we
can get as many people in as we possibly
can Mark Menzies thank you Mr Deputy
speaker as always it's a great pleasure
to follow the member for Commando can
Loudoun anyone listening to us can
clearly tell we come from the same part
of the world but Mr Speaker on to the
the matter before us today it's a matter
which is of great importance uh to my
constituency of filed and if I begin by
saying to the treasury bench that my
vote today is very much conditional
conditional and what uh the the
secretary of state has already um said
conditional what the Prime Minister said
to me today uh during premises questions
but it's no secret that I would much
rather the moratorium remain in place
and a moratorium that was a manifestal
commitment a manifest commitment which
each and every one of us on this side of
the house stood on campaigned on and was
elected on and that's a manifest of
commitment they said we will not support
fracking unless the sign shows
categorically that it can be done safely
Winfield will not forget that fracking
in our communities has twice led to
National moratoriums for people in filed
this is not a debate of what might
happen it's about not repeating events
that have happened events that have
impacted on our Countryside our people
our homes our communities
I continue and I always have
to take an evidence-based approach
but the geology has not changed nor has
the science
the industry has had more than a decade
to show that fracking can be carried out
safely and filed
every time they have tried the same
thing has happened we cannot keep doing
the same thing and hope for a different
outcome
the 2019 seismic events proved this
the only conclusion on evidence that I
can reach is that filed and its geology
remain wholly unsuitable for fracking
and I say to the party opposite had this
motion remain unamended
then I simply could not have supported
the government today
but as someone with genuine concerns
about this matter I am thankful to the
party opposite for giving this house the
opportunity to debate a critical issue
but on this I'm afraid they have gone
too far
because simply taking control of the
order paper is not something I can
support as I similarly opposed it during
the brexit votes and I am unwilling to
open that Pandora's Box again because
once we do
Mr Dave speaker where on Earth does it
end
but the one thing and my only objective
is to get the right outcome for the
people of files
may I gently remind the party opposite
that it was the last Labor government
that issued the fracking licensees in
files but they issued those those
licensees without the gold standard of
regulations that I fought for for many
years and secured
this included the traffic light system
and the seismic limit of 0.5 both of
which the fracking industry signed up to
the 2.9 event impressed New Roads in
August 2019 was
251 times more powerful than the
industry's own safety limit
and reply to me this afternoon the Prime
Minister mentioned that she would look
at very much at the regulations
well I Archer on the government to
ensure that any look at regulations has
at its heart the desire to maintain a
safe approach to seismic limits so where
the limits to be raised to 3.5 betting
in my impression year old was 2.9 if the
industry was to have its way it knows
limits were to be raised to say 3.5
that would be 1 000 times more powerful
than the previous limit of 0.5 and 4
times more powerful than the August 2019
event the event that led to the Second
National moratorium so my vote is based
on the good faith that the Prime
Minister has shown my constituents and
myself over recent weeks and in promises
that she made earlier in this house
can I also just say to the Secretary of
State but he is very much excited by the
prospect of local compensation and
incentives local communities do not
confuse that with a thought that
communities can be bought the people
have filed are not for sale the
principles are not up for auction and
they will look at this on the facts and
the safety merits first and foremost on
that and so please don't confuse it I'll
have the giveaway yeah I thank the
honorable Judge for giving way and he
may not be aware but when the fracking
was happening in Flight I actually came
out there to protest against it and can
I also say to him over that you're
talking about people being carried with
this bottom South East and the whole of
the Northwest has been against fracking
so I would ask the secretary of state
who's listening today let's certainly we
the North West do not want fracking
I'd like
thankful and that stands on its own but
just coming back to the point in front
of us today in his letter the secretary
of state has confirmed that the
government will launch a consultation
next month to assess her local consent
is to be gauged and has committed to put
this vote to the house that is something
I welcome can I also welcome that the
secretary of state has agreed uh today
to to ensure that there is in effect a
local uh veto for whatever want uh words
you want to give it that the voices of
people in that field will be listened to
in a fair way a transparent way in an
independent way and I thank the
Secretary of State for listening to that
it is not up to fracking companies to
determine what a local consent exists an
independent transparent way must be
found which is an alternative to that
and I thank the treasury bench for
agreeing to it and can I also make clear
that it's important that the local
planning process must remain in place
and that we rely vote he didn't feral to
ensip because once again if we are
committed to localism I can think of no
more important issue than the one before
the house today
But ultimately I'm I am able to vote for
this amendment because I believe that
people are filed share my conviction
that the answer for our communities is
no to fracking and when they say no to
fracking I expect the government to
deliver and to hear that no does mean no
I welcome I will give way yeah
we also agree that this is not only
about seismic activity and it is not it
is absolutely about
um local consent but it is also about
climate change and that the government
should really listen to the committee of
climate change and and produce a report
about the climate impact of fracking
The Honorable lady makes a very
important point I'm going to just
actually say on the issue of energy
security there's nobody more committed
to energy security myself we we
manufacture all the nuclear fuel for the
UK and my constituency at Westinghouse
but in order to make up the shortfall of
the amount of gas that we import we will
be looking at drilling somewhere in the
region of six to ten thousand Wells
I mean so the the quantities of what
we're talking about is astronomical and
the time scales involved it's not that
we we're not going to get gas into the
network anytime uh in the next two years
there's no infrastructure to get the gas
from these whales into the Grid or the
alternative as you build gas-fired power
stations in order to turn it into
electricity and feed it in three wires
again the time skills involved just
simply don't exist so the energy
security argument important load is
doesn't even stack up in the time scales
that the government is talking about so
on to conclude Mr Deputy speaker you
know I welcome the fair transparent and
meaningful consultation that both the
Prime Minister and the my honorable
friend the secretary of state is
committed to today that gives the people
a file the opportunity to reject
fracking but it more importantly it
gives the people who filed an
opportunity to have their voice heard
thank you much point of order event
Cooper yeah Mr Deputy speaker the Home
Secretary has been sacked or resigned
this afternoon this is
otter chaos the Prime Minister appears
to have appointed and sacked both a
Chancellor and a Home Secretary two of
the great offices of State in the space
of six weeks this is no way to run a
government Mr W speaker have you had any
indication from the Prime Minister that
she will come to this house to answer
questions from this the Home Secretary
the right on the former Home Secretary
the right honorable member for faram
says in her resignation letter that she
sent an official document draft written
ministerial statement on migration from
her personal email which she says was
due for publication and was against the
rules it raises huge questions about why
a Home Secretary who was responsible for
security was breaching basic rules there
are also rumors that in fact this
statement on migration she refers to had
not been agreed across the government
that there were major disagreements and
that this had been blocked by the
chancellor she also says in her
statement she has concerns about the
direction of the government about the
breaking of key pledges and says very
pointedly that the uh we haven't when we
have made mistakes and hoping things
will magically come right is not serious
politics there is clearly a huge chaos
at the heart of the government Mr Deputy
speaker home Affairs is far too
important for this kind of chaos this is
about security Public Safety and the
issues covered by the great offices of
State given that the government seems to
just be imploding Mr Speaker Deputy
speaker we clearly need not simply a
change of Home Secretary but a change of
government can we get a new statement to
this house
I'd like to thank the UI to honorable
lady for her point of order and her
advance notice of it I was made aware of
the departure of the Home Secretary
in the usual way
um
but
but she is asking the question as to
whether I have been notified in a usual
way as to whether there would then be a
statement I have not been notified as
such but should the situation change
then members will be notified via the
annunciator and other means so as it
stands at this moment there are no
statements to be made today
we're still on the six minute limit and
then we drop to four minutes
it causes disruption and distress to
local communities and crucially it will
not provide the clean secure energy that
our country needs and that was laid out
I think very effectively by my right
little friend on the front Branch when
he opened the debate earlier I have a
former exploratory site for fracking at
Barton moss in my constituency the
Energy company igas drilled the site to
a depth of about ten thousand feet in an
exploratory exercise over the course of
six months between 2013 and 2014.
during that time there was much local
opposition and a fierce protest which
resulted in months of demonstrations
150 police officers were involved in
policing the protest every day and a
total of 120 people were detained
greater Manchester police had to pay 1.7
million pounds for the cost of policing
the protest which came out of our local
policing budget
at the time the Manchester Evening News
run a survey of 2 500 local residents
this showed that over three quarters of
local people were opposed fracking I
want to explain why have I I have always
opposed fracking and why the reasons for
my constituents or position are so
Justified
some of the issues are local to Barton
Moss the exploratory fracking site is
close to an area of raised peat bog
which is a rare and precious resource
where it hasn't been ruined by over
extraction there are real concerns among
my constituents about dewatering those
precious Muslims and the harmful effects
of pumping water into underground rock
to force out the Shale gas in this
mossland area
people are also very concerned about air
pollution which is particularly worrying
at Barton moth because the site is next
to the m62 motorway itself a cause of
high levels of pollution
other environmental risks are not
specific to Barton Moss but they do have
an extensive evidence base
I want to quote from a report by the
Tyndall Center for climate change
research produced by local academics at
the University of Manchester
the depth of shale gas extraction gives
rise to Major challenges in identifying
categorically Pathways of contamination
of groundwater by chemicals used in the
extraction process
an analysis of these substances suggests
that many have toxic carcinogenic or
other hazardous properties there is
considerable anecdotal evidence from the
United States that contamination of both
ground and surface water has occurred in
a range of cases
so perhaps the government should listen
to its own experts a few weeks ago the
British Geological Survey published a
report on fracking which was
commissioned by the government it said
hydraulic fracturing can trigger
earthquakes large enough to cause
structural damage these events were not
predicted in advance of operations
clearly the science does not show
categorically that fracking can be done
safely for the government to allow
fracking now therefore just breaks
another election promise
on this yes indeed for giving away she
was speaking earlier about the protests
and her constituency as a honorable
member perhaps the only honorable member
in this house to have been arrested uh
tried and acquitted for uh protesting
about fracking does she share my
concerns about the public order bill
that was passed yesterday that actually
the peaceful protest which is entirely
legitimate around things like fracking
might well be closed down by the
Draconian piece of legislation
absolutely yes indeed and of course we
voted against that yesterday
friend give way she's making a very very
powerful case on behalf of her
constituents but does she share my
puzzlement
the government has made a screeching
U-turn today because it has finally
committed to a local veto
and every member who was spoken
representing areas where there has been
fracking or there might be frackings
made it quite clear there is no Prospect
of getting local consent there will be a
veto everywhere why why are we going
through this whole process when every
one of us knows what the outcome's going
to be
it's a puzzle to be as it is to to my
writable friend
um going back to the report of the
British geographical survey Geological
Survey on the same day on which this
report was published the business
secretary announced his intention to
revisit the safety limits on fracking he
said tolerating a high degree of risk
and disturbance appears to us to be in
the National interest I don't know if
that answers my friends question but
it's it's it's weird now his Amendment
indicates he will seek clear advice on
seismic limits and safety which is it
tolerating earthquakes and dangerous
Tremors or listening to the evidence
commissioned by his own Department Mr
Deputy speaker fears about pollution
contaminated water supply and seismic
events are by no means far-fetched an
earthquake caused by fracking near
Blackpool measured 2.9 on the Richter
Scale it led to the works being stopped
immediately and the company responsible
apologizing other concerns about
drilling for Shale gas extend beyond the
environmental in 2014 a defer report
forecasts that house prices were likely
to Fall by up to seven to seven percent
within a mile of fracking Wells and that
the price of house insurance would also
rise within five miles of fracking Wells
it is right that we end our alliance on
Rotten oil and gas but frocking is
neither the solution nor part of the
solution the government should instead
be focusing on boosting the UK's use of
renewable and nuclear energy
fracking is an issue of great importance
to my constituents and voting on it
should not be used as a confidence vote
by this failing conservative government
trying to bully its members into line
and there is an alternative Labor's plan
for energy would quadruple offshore wind
and double onshore wind capacity and
instead of blocking new solar projects
as the fly minister is planning to do
labor would triple solar power which is
up to nine times cheaper than gas it is
irresponsible to revisit the question of
fracking when we know it will have
profound environmental impacts and make
life very difficult for those people
living near a fracking site it's
ignoring what happened in the past it's
ignoring scientific and expert opinion
it's Reckless and it's dangerous
the flimsy measures in the government's
amendment to today's motion are another
case of moving the goalpost to achieve
their own aims before it was safety but
the report they commissioned isn't to
their liking now it's about consent but
the Secretary of State should know that
we already have a robust system of local
consent he called listening I know my
constituents don't want fracking because
they have made it very clear indeed so
when Mr Deputy speaker I ask Will the
government respect the evidence respect
the experts and the public and finally
put this threat of this awful process of
fracking to rest yeah moving to four
minutes Craig McKinley Mr speaker now we
often wonder why we're not taken very
seriously in this house
and I'll tell you why
we're in the depths of an energy crisis
we have shown ourselves being too
reliant Europe as a whole on a dictator
yeah
who has been uh conducting an illegal
War and the problems have come home to
roosters
and here we are
speaking about trying to ban a source of
domestic energy while we are short of it
and we wonder why people out there think
we are Stark staring mad
but of course today's debate isn't about
fracking it doesn't matter fracking at
all it's about taking control of the
order paper and we saw that before
during the height of the brexit wars my
dear friend's heading opposite uh was
part of that nuisances but I'm really
sorry that the member for Doncaster
North is in his place because I I did
try and intervene on him yeah he didn't
show me that courtesy if he'd been in
his place I'd have shown him the
courtesy now
because there are a couple of things
that I think need to be said it's been
raised here that it will make no
difference to the price of gas now I
don't know about anybody else in this
house but when I did O Level economics
the first week no probably the first
lesson it said if you put more of a
supply of something into a system the
price tends to come down
is it
but further than that further than that
even if even if labor economics are true
that the price will not change
would you rather would one rather
spend tens of billions of pounds per
year on foreign imported LNG even at a
high price or would we rather be
spending that money at home I think
that's a very clear decision
I would refer them no I won't give away
him got time today and others haven't
done anything I will get an oh Madam
please yes do it gives me another
another minute thank you I thank him for
giving way has he not listened to his
own colleague that
and secondly that his own that his own
um uh colleague when he was still um the
base secretary said only a few weeks ago
that no amount of fracked fuel in this
country will make a difference to the
global gas market because the quantities
are too small
well I'm thank the liberal Democrat
member for being uh on her feet for that
point because I do remember a former
leader of the liberal Democrats saying
about 12 years ago uh what is the point
in nuclear because it will take about 11
or 12 years to get it on stream I think
that 10 11 12 years back uh onward from
2010 would be about now and that would
have been quite useful of course it will
take time to get frat gas out the ground
the best time to have done it was a few
years ago the second best time to think
about it is now
I would refer members to a House of
Commons Library report dated 14th of
January of this year and it's called the
energy price crunch as ever House of
Commons Library reports are excellent
but this one was very clear
table 4.2 it has a very easy chart and
let me describe it to members it has the
output of UK produced gas from the North
Sea and that peaked at around
2004 where we were net exporters of gas
since then to now we are actually using
only about 75 of that Peak use that we
once uh used in the country that may be
for many reasons we may have better
insulated houses that's to the good
I feel pretty sure one of the main
reasons is that any higher energy
intensive business has simply offshored
somewhere else but let's just book that
aside
what has happened really distinctly is
we are now only producing a third
of what we did at Peak so we're using 25
percent less
we are
producing only a third of what we once
did where do you think that Gap is
coming from
app is coming from International
resources
I mean there are three countries alone
forgetting Norway
64 billion pounds we've spent over the
last 10 years on importing LNG from
Russia Qatar and the US
now surely it's got to be better to have
those jobs at home tens of thousands of
them that investment at home many
billions
tax revenues remember that profits and
tax revenues pretty helpful you know
that pays for things the NHS perhaps for
the installation that we'd all very much
support your ages and you know what
would be quite useful balance of
payments because we have always running
a pretty bad show on that but if CO2 is
your thing and it's certainly my thing
why are we importing LNG
5 million tons of extra CO2 just in the
process of importing it rather than
doing it domestically yeah so anyway
this debate is a there's a big one it's
for other reasons that we're very aware
of because uh uh shown by labor but I
support fracking let's give it a go
there is no government money involved
all private thank you very much Bill
esterson
County council's ecology advisor
described Aurora's assessment of
earthquake risk at the alt car Moss
fracking site as superficial outdated
and not justified
well my constituents nearby inform me
agree with the ecology advisor
because their houses shook when tests
were carried out and my constituents
have been saying for years that the
conservative plan is a charter for
earthquakes because that's been their
experience as elsewhere nearby in
Lancashire
conservative MPS stood on a Manifesto
which said we will not support fracking
unless the science shows categorically
it is safe
changing the safety threshold doesn't
change the level of risk and changing
the safety threshold when the science
hasn't changed won't convince my
constituents or people across the
country either
I can tell the government that people in
Sefton and in West Lancashire are not
going to support fracking and if the
government think they can manipulate
fake consent people simply won't be
fooled and that's for the impact on the
environment
the environment agency says
contamination of groundwater has not
been addressed by fracking companies
Natural England say that fracking
applicants haven't produced evidence
that their plans would have no
significant effects on Wildlife either
turning them to the government's claims
first the gas price fracking won't help
because the price is set by the Europe
on the European market
second the immediate challenge of Supply
fracking will take time
to produce gas even if the government
chooses to ignore local people it won't
deliver in the short term third climate
producing more fossil fuels is just
going to make the climate crisis worse
haven't we seen enough evidence of the
acceleration of the climate crisis with
storms floods and extreme heat in this
country let alone around the world
we need to do everything we can to end
our alliance on greenhouse gas producing
fuel introducing fracking will add
carbon emissions to our atmosphere Flack
it fracking is climate action delay and
to delay is to deny the reality that we
Face a column climate disaster and all
its consequences unless we act with all
speed the only sensible Way Forward is
to invest in wind and solar to deliver
renewable electricity self-sufficiency
as we on this cut this side of the house
will do by 2030 to invest in new
insulating 19 million homes to invest in
new nuclear in Tidal in hydrogen in
carbon capture and storage to create a
publicly owned Great British Energy
company we can be proud of and which
will deliver in the National interest
there are a million jobs in Labor's
energy plan there are lower bills there
is energy security
Labor's long-term plan will create a
world-leading renewable energy industry
where we can export our technology
around the world our plan is the right
way to address the energy challenge
fracking is completely the wrong way
whether it's in Formby or anywhere else
in Britain
my constituents are right to oppose
fracking and labor in government will
make that investment in renewable energy
and ban fracking for good yeah Robin
Walker Mr Deputy speaker I do not
support ending the moratorium on
fracking as I don't believe that new
scientific evidence has yet emerged
which would justify this it has been
welcomed to hear in recent days the
Prime Minister and the chancellor
talking about the importance of our 2019
Manifesto and I agree with both when it
comes to the triple lock on pensions and
the moratorium on fracking I do suggest
um that the I do support the UK as the
secretary of state has said maximizing
its domestic supply of gas to support
transition to Net Zero the production of
the support for new technologies for
heating including hydrogen for heating
and the importance of our supplies for
our energy security but we should do so
in ways that are proven to be safe I
will not vote for the opposition motion
today and I urge all colleagues in on
our side of the house not to do so as
this is a blatant attempt to seize
control of the order paper as they tried
to do so many times in their efforts to
thwart brexit I welcome the assurances
of my right honorable friends on the
front bench but there will be
consultation with parishes councils and
other local bodies to ensure that there
is a tough requirement for local consent
but I don't think there can really be
such a thing unless
committees can simply say no if they do
but I can't see how fracking is ever
likely to impact on Energy prices
certainly not in time to impact heating
costs this year or the next and I've
ever want to put on record my concerns
and those of thousands of my
constituents Let's Take Action to help
people with the cost of living protect
our environment and deliver on our 2019
Manifesto
thank you very much we now come to Lynn
Brown Mr Speaker frankly it's becoming
difficult to adequately express my
horror at the state of this government
every single decision seems calculated
to destroy destroy our economy our
public services our International
reputation and our environment too this
utter nonsense about fracking is another
example truth is there's very little
Prospect of fracking in West Ham and I
don't think our communities are going to
be affected by consequent earthquakes or
polluted Water Supplies but over recent
weeks I've had loads of emails from
constituents extremely concerned about
the direction that the government's
taking they're worried about how the
communities that could be affected
because they know how the local consent
can be and is manipulated to suit
agendas of the powerful my constituents
point to the constant Tory failure to
prevent vile sewage pollution and they
asked why anybody would trust the
government if it says that fracking
World won't destroy local Water Supplies
the party opposite has proven time and
time again they're simply not willing or
capable to stop greedy companies whether
they're privatized water utilities or
frackers from destroying our environment
in the pursuit of profit the issue of
fracking is about the safety of our
world and the future of our children and
so of course the people of West Ham want
to have their say they don't want us to
respond to the cost of living crisis by
simply increasing our dependence on the
exact same technologies that destroyed
it they don't want to pretend that
fracking can make a difference to energy
costs blight in our lives because it
won't so my constituents want us to get
to work on speeding up the green
transition that they've been promised
they point out quite rightly that wind
and solar power are enormously cheaper
enormously cheaper than gas and that
these Technologies are getting more and
more efficient with every passing year
in this place we need to focus a focus
from government to plan to invest and to
lead Partnerships with green business we
know that if we do there will be a huge
economic benefit in terms of lower
energy bills and jobs in all of our
communities and if we do that we can
slash our dependents on fossil fuels
from Russia and from other
anti-democratic bullying States we can't
move away from that dependence though by
extracting fossil fuels at home there
ain't enough of it and the cost social
economic and environmental is way too
high and we're rapidly approaching cop
27. effectively we are asking and
expecting poor African States like the
DRC to do the right thing and develop
their economies with minimum amount of
dirty energy we're talking about
countries who have much larger fossil
reserves than us enormously lower
emissions than us and a much higher
vulnerability to climate heating than us
and we're asking them to choose a
Greener path to development where
ministers here are shamefully speaking
about extracting and I quote every last
drop it's Madness as in this energy
strategy it will be devastating for
local communities who transparently
don't want it and it drives a wrecking
ball through the patient climate
diplomacy that this world desperately
needs
yeah
Instagram
Mr Deputy speaker um there is of course
one great example of fracking in West
Ham which is fracking good football
which many of us saw at Upton Parker now
at the new stadium but today is an
interesting debate because unfortunately
for all the eloquence of the right
honorable member for Doncaster North who
made in many ways a very good speech
about some of the hazards of fracking it
has been spoiled by the three and a half
pages which is all about a procedural
takeover of this chamber so that I'm
afraid rules out voting for the labor
motion straight away now the interesting
contribution from the SNP focused on the
fact that in the honorable member for
kilmarnock's view there is no support
for fracking anywhere in the country and
we've heard echoes of this from several
members from the opposition benches now
I do not support fracking I don't think
it should happen I don't think it will
happen but this is a democracy and it is
perfectly possible that there are parts
of the country it might be South than it
you might be Ashfield it might be
elsewhere which do support fracking not
in the center of the city of Gloucester
no
but there is perfectly possible in a
democracy listen
that there are places in the country
which might support it and that is where
the question which the right honorable
member himself raised in 2013 which the
leader of the liberal Democrat Party has
said before is vital is the question of
local concept now
I do think that the secretary of state
is on a journey on this he started
frankly by assuming that local consent
could be a consultation done by the
fracking company of the few houses
around where a fracking site might
happen that was clearly not sustainable
it's clearly not genuine consultation it
clearly does not take into account
enough views my own view for what it's
worth is that the two crucial elements
of local consent which I hope you will
bring back to the house after his
consultation is firstly local planning
control not by the inspectorate
nationally and secondly and this is is
also uh I I think important in terms of
local consent a recognition that local
councils are the expression of local
democracy that is absolutely at the core
of compassionate conservative values and
I think shared by many people across the
house and that vote by a full council is
the most important part with those two
considerations and I hope the party man
managers are listening a free vote on
the floor of the house the party
managers are talking amongst themselves
but I hope they're listening a free vote
when the local consent definition comes
back to this house will give everyone
here the absolute confidence that there
will be no fracking in any constituency
unless there is absolute local support
and that is the crucial question today I
give away of course
the steps to speak of the interest to
house I'm very sorry the new members of
the Scottish national party whether it's
just now it is a fact that where
councils in Scotland make a planning
decision for instance to refuse a wind
farm application is quite frequently
overturned by the Scottish government
so the rhetoric about local power
can be Hollow The Honorable member makes
a very good point and it's it's
disappointing in a way that um members
of this house from the SNP are not here
to hear that point because they're huge
supporters in theory of renewable energy
and
can I just can I just very quickly
answer the point on on renewable energy
because there is a great deal that the
secretary of state has said and written
not least in a very good article in the
guardian a week ago about renewable
energy which is excellent and we would
all get behind so would all I suspect
members of the opposition parties I
would love him to do more hold on one
second I'd love him to do more on
supporting tidal lagoons which could
have been done by now in Swansea they
seemed expensive at the time they seemed
very good value now there is a lot that
more that can be done on Marine energy
which contributes to base load and there
are lots of other things rules on
onshore floating offshore you name all
of those he is absolutely on the right
track and so is this government and
members and The Wider public should
recognize this this government is doing
a huge amount on Renewables but this
question of local consent on fracking is
critical can I give way first of my
honorable friend and then to daughter
I'm obliged to him for giving ways very
generous to do so would not the answer
to the question being put to him by the
liver Or democrats be my suggestion
earlier that one removes the right to
appeal to an inspector in fracking
applications and allows the local
planning authority to be the final
determinant of it well he's absolutely
right I mean so often Yorkshire men are
right aren't they the minister knows all
about that but the key thing is that
local planning approvals should be
absolutely at the heart of the
definition of local consent I give way
to honorable I'm grateful it will be
brief the Secretary of State used the
word veto a lot of objection it was a
veto so there's no business of appeals
or anything else because if the local
community veto it it's dead strangled
kaput
well I think we're all broadly in
agreement on that I hope the ministers
are in listening mode on this I do think
that the perfect solution would have
been to get back to the 2019 Manifesto
which the prime minister's urged us to
do in so many instances and therefore to
have got back to the moratorium that we
were at that was a settled position the
whole country accepted it but
nonetheless I recognize there are some
colleagues who think there may be virtue
and the as the Secretary of State likes
to say his nine word Mantra Everything
Has Changed because of Putin's invasion
of Ukraine that is true and there may be
worse to come who knows what nuclear
weapons might be deployed and what
impact that has on energy and all the
rest so we should accept and I think the
labor party should accept also it is
possible that there is a role for Shale
gas should the scientific evidence
support it should local consent indicate
that they do support it and it is fair
enough for the Secretary of State to say
we should look at it but I urge him to
have a free vote on that definition when
it comes back to the house
thank you oh cat Smith
Madam speaker fracking again and to be
honest Madam speaker since the moment I
was elected to this house I've been
speaking I think in probably every
single debate on this subject because
for my constituents in Lancashire this
is something that really matters it has
a tangible effect on their lives with
the fracking application uh on Preston
new road and rosica
um in my own friends constituency and it
matters because of the climate emergency
which I think that we risk losing sight
of if we keep focusing purely on
tackling the energy crisis and cost
living crisis as important as they are
we cannot forget that the planet is
burning and therefore all of the
conversations we have around energy have
to bear in mind that we use a climate
emergency and that needs to be addressed
now for a bit of background
um after I was elected in 2015 the
County council at Lancashire passed its
first motion opposing fracking that was
followed three months later by a
Lancaster City Council passing a motion
against fracking and then of course uh
quadrilla get the permission and they
start fracking at Preston new road and
at that point we see subsequent motions
objects into fracking from councils
across the county including Lancaster
City Council passing its second motion
and it was clear that there was
cross-party consensus and huge public
dismay about fracking which is why in
2019 during the general election when
the conservative party changed its
policy and suddenly Manifesto that
pledged to ban fracking I think there
was a sense of widespread relief in our
red rose County because there was like
cross-party consensus the people of
Lancashire thought that the issue had
been put to bed they thought that they
could be safe knowing that there wasn't
going to be earthquakes safe that there
wasn't going to be fracking Wells Lister
in the foul Coast but no fracking is
back and we still don't want it local
councilors of all political colors are
backing motions at councils right across
the county including in this week alone
one it filed and one at Lancashire
County Council both Tory run councils
voting unanimously to pass anti-frecking
motions and
what counselors are telling me is that
they do not understand what this local
concern looks like they do not know what
it looks like and suppose my question to
the minister is what on Earth does he
mean by local consent many people have
been very concerned by the business
secretary's comments the Conservative
Party Conference uh talking about
fracking companies going door to door to
Canvas support for fracking I do hope
that will not be included in the
consultation and I would like it if the
minister for climate change could rule
that out in his closing remarks to this
debate the people of Lancashire don't
want to have fracking forced upon them
yes we live in tough times yes the
energy bills are going up but fracking
will not solve the energy security or
the price issues in the UK currently
faces
we need to see the government put in far
more energy into looking at energy
reduction home insulation and frankly
the only viable long-term route to lower
bills and energy Security is to get off
fossil fuels and fortunately for the
minister the answers stirring us uh
clear in the face because clean energy
like solar wind tidal hydrogen and
nuclear are all options which this
government should be throwing its full
weight behind and it's why the last
Labor leadership at Lancaster City
Council led the way installing solar
panels on public buildings like our
Solitaire sports center it's why the big
Employers in my constituency like
Lancaster University is seeking
permission for more wind turbines it's
why local businesses like nanoson and
Lancaster are looking to harness
hydrogen and why the nuclear power
stations at Hisham wanted to provide my
constituents with thousands of jobs
Lancashire will play its part with
enthusiasm in a green energy Revolution
we know it makes sense when solar and
wind power for example are nine times
cheaper than gas but fracking no thanks
fracking is expensive it's unsafe and we
know that communities in Lancashire do
not support it
thank you as the host can see there are
great many people who wish to speak and
we have very little time left so after
the next contribution I will have to
reduce the time limit to three minutes
Alexander Stafford thank you thank you
very much indeed my dear speaker I Rise
to reaffirm my opposition to fracking in
brother Valley I believe I'm the only
colleague in the house who not only has
two potential thrashing sites in my
constituency heart to Wood sets but who
also actually lives in one of those
Villages threatened in Harts Hill
my position since being elected has been
consistent I oppose fracking in our area
and it was indeed the very first thing I
spoke about in the House of Commons
chamber of being elected and indeed I
rebelled against the government on the
issue in May 2021 be the only
conservative to actually vote about all
fracking including exploitation
exploration
therefore I was looking forward to
reconfirming this in the house today
but the motion before us is not about
fracking it's about confidence in this
government it is about who runs the
country the elected party the
conservatives or labor or who lost the
general election
this unfortunately is a cynical attempt
by labor to play party for this okay
this is not again these are people's
lives these are people's communities
division to weaponize this issue rather
than working together on a cross-party
basis
yeah and this better deaf speaker is
what's wrong the state of our politics
all that matters is cheap they're
laughing Etc They're laughing at
people's hearts ill they are laughing
people with wood sets because these are
cheap Point scoring ultimately chasing
misleading headlines rather than working
with us on this side of the house to
make better policy for our communities
let me get clear fracking is unnecessary
it's harmful to environment and will
have no impact on the international gas
prices it is yesterday's technology and
not an answer to today's problems now
I've had several meetings the business
secretary on this matter and we have
heard him today at this chamber and he
has made it crystal clear that there
must be majority of local independent he
said Community sport in order to frankly
proceed he used the words evito
but let's be honest in some parts of the
country there may indeed be that support
now let me hear this clear I am the
elected member part of rather value I'm
not the member for Rhonda I represent
heart Hill not Hartlepool wood sets not
working who am I dictate the rest of the
UK or other communities want that is
undemocratic
what is clear though in my local
Villages is there is no Community sport
for fracking and we have today been
given a cast iron guarantee that these
changes will last but communities even
down to the parish level at the heart of
any future decision no more worries
about the changing nature of Dutch
government
and those that are directly defected by
this will ultimately have the last say
and that is correct
now halt Helen Wood sets are riddled
with Old Mine Workers and the fault
lines are already severely weakened by
Cold extractions right beneath the
company's wish to Frank
my constituents do not wish to live next
to Industrial sites the traffic movement
associated with fracking says a huge
risk to production of safety and could
destroy local floor and fauna and ruin
the unsupport countryside
however and even the post item was sets
is only yards from resenter home of the
elderly and vulnerable which is deep
depressor now let me vet this clear
again I am against fracking in World
Valley
but I'm also against the disgraceful
attempt by labor to overturn the
government
the government policy today is announced
is more power to local residents to
reject backing I want them to drag back
in and I can reassure this house that
when there is that local community vote
the vote that actually matters
communities and as a resident of Harts
hill I'll be getting a voting this I
will not only be voting against fraction
while the valley I will be leading the
charge on this issue
now on a time limit of three minutes Tim
fahren okay I'm very grateful and so why
on Earth would the government seek to
perform another Manifesto U-turn and
support fracking which if their
Amendment does effectively lift the
moratorium on fracking there are two
reasons which are stated one is an
attempt to drive down Energy prices the
other is to tackle security of Supply
those are two massive issues enormous
energy poverty in my constituency in
Cumbria and everybody rightly worried
about the lack of energy security given
particularly the evil actions of uh
President Putin and but if those were
the real reasons you wouldn't pick
fracking and I'm absolutely astounded
and amused as to why they have the right
honorable member for spellthorne the
former chance of the exchequer uh stated
that it would not materially affect the
market price for gas that's obvious so
that's pricing out of the window the
fracking industry Lobby say the lobby
group says that Shale gas would
contribute less than one percent of
Britain's gas needs and the British
Geological Survey says that Shale gas on
the United Kingdom can't it boots 15
times Less in volume than was originally
thought so it will have no impact on
price and it will do nothing meaningful
when it comes to volume so what it will
do is add another fossil fuel into the
mix at a time when we should be keeping
all the fossil fuels in the ground
because of all the threats that we face
as a country as a community climate
change is undoubtedly the greatest
fossil fuels should be kept in the
ground it will also create massive
seismic risks the northwest of England
Cumbria and Lancashire to the most
geologically active places in the
country fracking is madness using an
opting for fracking is divisive and
expensive whereas Renewables are popular
and cheap on that point happily yeah
I've again again speaker have gone on
about green uh energy and hydrogen
creation hydrogen is green and clean
we've got to get serious about this and
William gives me that it's vital that
all the governments in the united can
work together fast and now I think greed
hydrogen is absolutely essential part of
the mix and I agree with my honorable
friend that if the government was trying
to change policy quickly in order to do
something that would radically make a
difference quickly then they will be
opting for Renewables the United Kingdom
uh is after Canada has the highest tidal
range on planet Earth and yet we are
tapping nearly none of it why are we not
investing in wind in Seoul allowing
Farmers to diversity for it by to be
Market part of the happily giveaway yes
just uh popped up it's very generous at
the time by the way but I wanted to
recall when your leader says I love
Shale gas it is much cleaner than coal
and we need more gas I hope we get loads
of it yes my leader when he was of
course Secretary of State for energy and
climate change was responsible for the
United Kingdom increasing Renewables by
20 every year which dropped by three
percent when he left office and if he's
concerned about leaders changing their
mind the party opposite is led by
someone with more flip-flops than
Benidorm so we are not going to take any
lessons from that side of the house the
Renewables are the answer they are quick
and they are popular my concern is that
why on Earth why on Earth would a govern
why on Earth there are other people who
need to get it and the minister needs to
be patient and wait his turn because my
concern in all this is what did this say
about the government it is not rational
to choose Shale gas and fracking at a
time when the it is obvious it will not
have an impact on reducing prices or
improve and energy security when instead
the government could be moving towards
uh tidal Marine Hydro wind and solar not
rational but what is also not rational
is the fact that earlier this day the
right honorable member for Calder Valley
the government Chief whip wrote to every
conservative MP saying that this matter
is not about fracking it is a matter of
confidence and this causes a great
problem for members opposite they either
have to vote to end the moratorium on
fracking which is enormously unpopular
only 19 of the British people support
fracking the overwhelm majority are
opposed to it including in my
constituency so they've either got a
support fracking or they've got to vote
to bring down the government that is a
an irrational thing for the government
to seek to put before this house and the
difficulty is we're beginning to see a
pattern of irrational Behavior at the
center of our government that if we care
about our energy supplies the cost of
energy the enormously painful cost of
living that is a threat to every single
family in this country we care about
those things our economy we cannot have
people in high office and leading the
government party who are acting
consistently logically illogically and
irrationally and this is an irrational
proposal and that is why it is right the
government should give way and why the
government we should be opposing
fracking and it's why I will be voting
to oppose fracking today I challenge
members opposite to ignore their whips
and vote to end fracking
Maria Caulfield thank you madam Deputy
speaker let me be clear for my
constituents I do not support fracking
and will not be voting for it in the
future but uh and it's very clear for my
constituents of their concerns I am
encouraging The Honorable member for
North Dorset um is quite right that the
secretary of state has given the
commitment that the local residents will
have a veto over any plans for fracking
so the moratorium stays in Sussex
because I'm pretty confident my
residents will not be supporting it but
can I just Echo the concerns around
planning where we are seeing on a daily
basis our refusals for planning being
overturned by the planning inspector and
I want reassurance from the minister
that that will not happen in cases of
fracking and maybe this is an
opportunity to look at the role of the
planning inspector overall as well as
looking at how we can respect the wishes
locally when it comes uh to fracking but
let's also be clear that this motion
today is to agree on the date when there
will be a vote on a bill to Brand
fracking is not actually a vote on
Banning fracking today and what I am
amazed at the uh the sheer brass neck of
the opposition is they are often
criticizing this government for having a
legislation rushed through having all
stages on one day and yet that's exactly
what they're proposing in their order
paper they often say these issues are
too important too many colleagues want
to speak there's not enough time to
debate amendments that is what is in
their motion today all stages of a bill
in one day is that the indication of
this government in waiting at those
so-called claim to be and just while I
have time Madam Deputy speaker we I
pointed out to the shadow Secretary of
State his hypocrisy in saying that he
did and he said this at the labor Party
Conference there was a role for fracking
when he was leader of the labor party uh
but it Bears no uh resemblance to the
brass neck of the liberal Democrats who
as usual when they were in government
say one thing and then when they're in
opposition say another
when the leader of the liberal Democrats
was the Energy Secretary not only did he
lift restrictions on fracking he also
voted against abandoned fracking in
2015. I asked my honorable friend said
was quoted in 2013 in saying there's an
awful lot of nonsense talked about
fracking I love Shell gas it's much
cleaner than coal we need more gas I
hope we get loads of it well I will say
the same thing to my constituents
whether uh today or tomorrow I will not
support fracking whether I'm a
government minister or I'm a back
venture and I will hope that we when
this does come to the floor in the house
I will not support fracking when it does
um that I will be uh my constituents
will see that I will stand by every word
that I say yeah
Stephanie peacock
speaker we will not support fracking
unless the science shows categorically
that it can be done safely that was the
2019 conservative Manifesto we will only
allow fracking where there is local
consent that was the Prime Minister in
her leadership bid this summer there is
no new science and there is no local
consent indeed in July this year the
government commissioned a report which
has already been quoted today from the
British Geological Survey investigating
the impact of fracking the reports
showed no new science but concluded that
forecasting earthquakes as a result of
fracking remained a challenge extracting
Shale gas through fracking in the hope
of offsetting the energy crisis will not
work implementing the process expensive
and returns simply not enough to make a
significant difference to our energy
sector it was the member for spell form
that stated that fracking won't
materially affect the wholesale market
price it would do nothing to cut bills
costing far more than Renewables and it
is unsafe even the founder of the
fracking company quadrilla has stated
that fracking is not safe nor viable in
the UK it is clear to see that nobody in
the UK other than the government wants
this plan to go ahead given that the 50
of the last round of fracking licenses
were in Yorkshire Pete Lynn Barnsley are
concerned about the government's
disastrous plans to reintroduce backing
only 17 of the public support the
practice the business secretary claimed
he would be happy to allow fracking in
his back Garden but he does not speak
for the rest of the country and he
certainly does not speak for the people
of Barnsley
Simon Hall thank you very much indeed
Madam Deputy speaker first of all can I
just thank uh my wife and referendum
Secretary of State he's a long-standing
friend for how he's approached today I
think the assurances he has given to the
house should be taking uh seriously and
with the sincerity with which he made
them and I think certainly have been uh
enormously helpful
my opposition to fracking is well known
and I would say to anybody who is
uncertain as to the merits of new
exploration and exploitation of fossil
fuels
watch on playback if you didn't see it
on Sunday the concluding episode of
Frozen Planet 2.
only an idiot
would think that our planet could
sustain new forms and new exploitations
of fossil fuels into our environment now
I'm absolutely convinced
and I'm not entirely sure why this has
been made a matter of confidence and I'm
still less certain Adam Deputy speaker
why her majesty his Majesty's government
has decided to resurrect what I thought
had been an issue which had been
interred quite properly some little
while ago
it's not going to happen
these are bald men fighting over a comb
it's not going to occur
no local community is going to Grant
consent
I would love to vote
against
fracking tonight
but like my honorable friend for Hazel
Grove
I want to keep my voice and my vote
to help shape the future of the party
I've been a member of since 1985.
and I'm not prepared to throw that away
on an issue which is actually
not as I say going to happen however and
I agree with those who have called for a
free vote there should be a free vote
once my right honorable friend has
undertaken the consultation and the
Matrix of that consultation has been
sorted out it is not however an esoteric
point to say this is a point of
principle his Majesty's opposition
should take control of the order paper
we have dare I say it quite enough chaos
at the moment without adding to it
it is a strange day when the labor party
is trying to hold us to a Manifesto
commitment I was proud to stand on in
2019 of maintaining a moratorium I think
the key thing is that the moratorium
remains in place
unless or until
a new regulatory system is put in place
Madam Deputy speaker listening to the
debate today and being privy to
conversations with many colleagues on
this side of the house over the last few
days it's my very firm belief that that
day will never Dawn
Kate hard thank you madam Deputy speaker
I would just like to remind members why
we're here today
the Satan press New Road rocked houses
damaged communities and terrified
residents and quite not just one patient
two or three occasions in quite rightly
the conservative government put a ban on
fracking until it could be convinced
that it was could be safely
drilled out
and caused little disruption to the
communities
the Prime Minister was on radio
Lancashire and we've got a very good
host
dream library
to congratulate him on his wedding
yesterday
but Graham cornered the Prime Minister
was
seconds
when he said what has changed she did
not have an answer and he has three or
four times and she still couldn't answer
she just kept saying she was very clear
that people would be consulted he asked
her what does that consultation look
like she didn't know
so members on the opposite side to
accuse this side of taking the order of
paper is an absolute joke
your government in the ban your
government says the ban would not be
lifted order it's not your government
it's their government
their government put in the ban their
government
said it would lift that ban when there
was safety assured that's not happened
so you can play politics and find an
excuse to vote against your conscience
but don't blame people on this side I do
not support fracking Lancashire does not
support fracking and the government has
failed to deliver any assurance that it
was safe thank you mother detective yeah
Lee Anderson
Mr Speaker
um now then um I love Shale gas
uh hope we get loads of it well we've
certainly had loads of it today coming
from the uh opposition Ventures uh but
it's not up to me uh and it shouldn't be
up for people in this place to decide
whether or not I want fracking to go
ahead in the country and the Prime
Minister has been she's been very
consistent to say that local people will
have the final say on whether or not
fracking goes ahead and we've learned
today that the local people will also
get a veto and that's the right thing
yeah here we have in this place I keep
coming to this place just to remind
myself most of the time out of touch a
lot of MPS are in this place because how
many people in this place found that the
speaker actually worry about what it's
like in bed at night to pay their gas
bill or their electric bill nobody in
this place worries about how to pay the
next bill that drops through the door
they would soon decide with the people
we've seen out on down the street today
gluing themselves to the to the pavement
again rather than think about the
hard-working taxpayer in places like
customer not once today is anybody
opposite inventors mentioned fuel
poverty at all not once all they've
banged on about is fracking in order to
possibly to save their own skin at the
general election
let's be clear nobody would support
fracking in their in their area if it
was dangerous and it didn't provide a
cheaper supply of gas or their
incentives to local communities we all
know that we're not daft
but the GMB Union who our labor party's
biggest funder as I believe they support
the idea of fracking and they say
and I quote if it can be shown to be
safe for workers and communities
fracking offers part of the solution to
the energy crisis
if the labor party disagree so much with
the GMB on this very important issue
then maybe they should stop accepting
donations
but of course I don't Deputy speaker
they won't do that let's be honest most
people don't think twice about when the
energy comes from when they switch the
kettle on in the morning they expect
electricity and gas to come to their
house they expect to be able to afford
it but my constituents are fed up now
with them to face increased energy bills
especially after seeing successive
governments give up on our own domestic
supply of fuel over the years and now
we're in a situation where we're
actually imported about 40 percent of
our gas this means money going to
foreign treasuries to foreign workers
when it could be done here but like I
say if local local communities in
Nashville don't want it I would support
them if there is a a community in
Nashville that did support it I would
support them I cannot understand why we
actually here even debate it other than
the Mischief of the labor party and you
can shake his head the the shadow sector
of Steak and Shake is had very well
please come to a place like Ashfield I
know you don't visit your own
constitutions very often but come to a
place like dashfield and talk to some
real people that's me don't mind
Olivia Blake
speaker and until recently the debate on
climate change was about the science and
whether or not Global heating is caused
by humans but it's important to say that
while the climate denial is argued over
the science and the hockey stick graphs
that wasn't what gave momentum to their
arguments to be clear there has been a
long overwhelming evidence that humans
CO2 emissions are causing Global Heating
the motor of climate denial was never a
rational scientific debate but defending
the financial interests of the fossil
fuel Lobby
pseudoscientific arguments were only the
the only form that they have of Defense
of their arguments and that's the
defense that they took now after Decades
of campaigning protesting and lobbying
the Monumental efforts of climate
campaigners have meant is politically
very difficult to deny the reality of
the climate emergency the overwhelming
scientific evidence has been joined by
the international Grassroots political
movement calling for climate justice so
now we're seeing a different strategy
for protecting oil and gas profits we're
now being asked to choose between
tackling the cost of living crisis or
the climate emergency between energy
security and meeting our Paris
obligations the decision to reverse
fracking is part of that new strategy a
very cynical strategy is an argument
that stays black is white that Up Is
Down and that pulling more fossil fuels
out of the ground is somehow a form of
environmentalism
but it's an argument we should
completely reject because it is nonsense
the twin ecological and climate
emergency are two of the greatest
existential threats we Face they demand
that we restore our natural environment
keep fossil fuels in the ground and make
a transition to clean renewable energy
fracking tapes is in exactly the
opposite direction
the CCC warned that if the moratorium
should be lifted and it should
absolutely not be lifted without an
independent review of the evidence on
the climate impact has that been done no
of course it's not been done the process
produces methane which also contributes
to the rising global temperatures
research by NASA has shown that leaky
gas production is one of the main
drivers of methane missions on the
planet in fact during one week alone in
a site in Lancashire in 2019 4.2 tons of
methane were released equivalent to 142
flights extracting Shale gas is also
environmentally damaging the geography
of the UK means that it's more likely to
cause earthquakes and the chemicals low
back and Waters
um being significantly at risk of
contamination and further significant
ecological damage and none of this will
lower our energy bills or increase our
energy security that's because gas
prices are answered by domestic Supply
but the international fossil fuel
markets even if domestic production did
significantly affect International
prices the wells here would not make a
difference to those prices it's a
falsehood
Ruth Edwards
today's debate is less about fracking
and more about the labor party's next
social media campaign
for if they had wanted to show the true
strength of The house's opinion on
fracking they could have tabled a normal
motion today calling for the moratorium
to be reintroduced at a later stage they
could have amended a bill going through
Parliament either of those routes they
had a reasonable chance of carrying many
colleagues on this side of the house
with them but instead they have chosen
the one route that they know no member
on this side of this house could
possibly support a confidence vote now I
don't support fracking Madam Deputy
speaker but I am even less keen on the
idea of letting the labor party play at
being in government for the day because
I remember what happened when they were
there last time yeah my views on most
things are no secret and certainly not
on fracking now I don't buy the argument
it's less environmentally friendly gas
is gas whether it's drilled here or
overseas and the carbon footprint of gas
produced in the UK is smaller than lngs
shipped in
I'm also not convinced by the argument
it's unsafe but I do think it's
unsuitable in a country like the UK
where we have a high population density
especially given that even relatively
small Tremors can be felt by the local
community
and it's the British Geological Survey
which has this HQ in rushcliffe has said
our ability to predict such Tremors has
not improved since the moratorium was
put in place
but my main objection to fracking is
that after all the division and local
anguishes it causes even the industry
itself estimates it will produce very
little gas we would be better off
focused on increasing the output from
our North Sea industry Renewables and
nuclear
I am relieved that we will have a
binding vote on the process for gaining
local consent this is vital
communities must know they have a
legally enforceable route to either
accept or reject fracking under their
homes
and my final observation tonight Madam
Deputy speaker is for our own front
bench for they have enabled the
opposition to force colleagues to choose
between voting against our Manifesto and
voting to lose the whip they should take
a look at the faces of colleagues behind
them colleagues who have fracking sites
in their constituencies and they should
hang their heads in shape a conservative
government will always have my
confidence Madam Deputy speaker but its
leadership today has severely tested my
trust and the trust of many colleagues
and I would advise them not to do so
again
Warren thank you madam Deputy speaker
the fight against climate change is one
that everyone but this government seems
to be deeply worried about in Wales we
are proud that our Welsh labor
government remains absolutely steadfast
in our fracking ban which has been in
place for seven years now and will
continue
so it's even more disturbing that this
prime minister absent of a public
mandate has decided to tear up her own
parties 2019 Manifesto and any hopes of
a stable future by bringing back
fracking and is it any surprise when
this government is imploding is the
Secretary of State even going to be here
tomorrow
it is heartening though to see members
on the opposite side
publicly declared their uh their their
support for us and against this
government's option on Twitter coming
out one at a time particularly the
member for Kingswood who is also chair
of the government's Net Zero review
I think that is quite telling this
energy crisis is costing lives action
absolutely needs to be taken to occur
more suffering but fracking is not the
answer it makes it worse and this crisis
has been created by an over-reliance on
oil and gas we can't increase it and
this government refuses to understand
that you can't tackle one crisis without
tackling the other but instead this
government has chosen to ignore the
warnings the science and please making a
deliberate attack not only on the
environment but Public Health too
in England alone a third of drinking
water is supplied by groundwater
the British Geological Survey stated
that groundwater can be contaminated by
fracking
one concerning risk is from flow back
water coming from fracking itself water
that flows back contains high
concentration of saline known to cause
hypertension which can lead to pregnant
women developing preeclampsia it
exposing the mother to potential stroke
risk organ failure with some babies
being still born
medical experts have written to the
British medical Journey stating these
arguments and in complete contrast is
government's own climate Minister has
claimed it's good for the environment
but that same Minister publicly
published his support for the ban of
March this year
fracking won't solve any of our energy
problems and it won't provide the
essential support the country needs
right now drilling is irrelevant to this
energy crisis let alone being a complete
abdication of Duty to the environment
local communities and the climate
this latest move drives a cart and
horses through any chance of credibility
on Global Leadership on climate they
must keep that ban now
Paul Maynard Deputy speaker I may ask
talk about praising the member for
Russia for this Focus so eloquently and
I endorse every word she has said about
how the government has handled this
matter and I share her attention to
despair frustration and infuriation by
it though I found myself saying so
frequently at the moment we are where we
are and we have to get on with it I
would much rather the moratorium that I
stood on manifested commitment to
implement could endure
but I have to welcome the commitment
from the Secretary of State to hold a
substantive vote on The process by which
consent will be determined but I Echo
those who have said that this should be
a free vote this is a polarizing issue
in my constituency opinion locally has
always been broadly opposed to fracking
which I've always respected and taken
notice of that there has always also
been a vocal supportive minority his
voices have become louder as higher
energy costs have begun to be felt even
if I can use not a solution to the
problem of higher energy prices and
everyone in my constituency deserves to
have their say to my aim of the recent
weeks have been to ensure that the
government to commitment to local
consent was a meaningful one and not one
place in the hands of companies such as
quadrilla any prefer should be
independent and do the local referendum
will be my preference because of all
areas of the phone Coast should be able
to participate in the discussions as
they will feel the consequences
Blackpool as a Unity Authority has no
involvement in Lancaster's planning
decisions but it will bear the
seismological consequences just as much
of the Parish of rosica wood and I am
particularly annoyed by suggesting the
financial inducement that will be profit
by the Shell gas company trying to
influence the decision making they must
not form part of the decision over
consent getting the consent system right
and that means it needs to be in a broad
area not a narrow Parish within 50
meters of some pad getting that right
although all my constituents either in
favor or against to feel that they had
had their voice listened to perhaps
fundamentally carried out under my
principles only rejection of fricking
locally would be a permanent people's no
on the record the opt-in temporary
politicians may be they could be verse
by yet another U-turn and yet another
new government which is what Labor's ban
I'm afraid officers let the people of
this country put on record their views
about fracking in their local area and
then we as politicians should pay
attention to that elect accordingly
great Davis
I am Deputy speaker we're here because
the previous uh Chancellor lifted the
moratorium on fracking and his previous
boss Crispin ODI of Audi hedge fund has
put millions and millions of pounds of
investment into into fracking now he's
the same one who made hundreds of
millions of pounds when the pound went
down following brexit having supported
leave he's the same one who made a lot
of money out of the Sterling going down
after the mini budget strange isn't it
so we've got a situation now the
government's lifting the moratorium so
you can go ahead with fracking so long
as you have safety and a local consent
so maybe that will be bribe we don't
know what will happen there but I don't
think that's sufficient because we need
to think about the environment I was
rapporteur of the Council of Europe uh
on fracking and what we found from
satellite data was that five percent of
the Methane have been pulled up was
actually leaked through fugitive
emissions which meant that fracking is
worse than coal for global warming
because methane is 80 times worse than C
CO2 and so we recommended 46 countries
that we knew and went ahead with
fracking as a result macron when he was
first elected he didn't have many
policies he took that policy off the of
the table and he banned fracking as we
have in fact in Wales because fracking
consists of sending millions of tons
millions of cubic meters of a chemically
impregnated water off the hundreds of
chemicals which are carcinogenic into
the ground half of them come back half
of them stay underneath so they can
contaminate the water table the rest
have to be processed in the United
States they dumped them in Arizona well
we're not the United States and we
haven't got the space we've got the
lorries running around the countryside
smashing up our environment we've got
many earthquakes causing disturbances
we've got air quality data for the
United States showing local people have
awesome runny eyes all sorts of problems
and as I say that's why in Wales we've
also banned it we're focusing on tidal
lagoons uh you know wind farms solar
energy spatial planning there is a way
forward for a sustainable green Energy
Future the answer is not fracking it's
environmentally unsound we should
dismiss it even if there was consent
even if it was safety concerns were
alleviated which they won't be this is
absolutely appalling this is Tory
fracking and she people should vote
labor because of this appalling decision
to lift the moratorium
Scott Benton thank you madam Deputy
speaker fracking is an issue which
ignites very strong feelings among my
constituents since the government
announced as changing direction on this
issue I've been very much looking
forward to a genuinely free and fair
debate in this place where I could go on
the record and outline my concerns and
those of thousands of my constituents
about fracking returning it to the foul
Coast however Madame Deputy speaker this
is most certainly not the free and fair
debate that I have been hoping for this
opposition day debate is a very
different Beast altogether this motion
is not about fracking at all but as an
attempt by the labor party to take over
the functions of government this would
overturn standing orders and the
procedures of this house which says that
only the elected governments of the day
gets to decide on Poland entry business
it would allow bit labor to legislate
against the wishes of my constituents
who elected a conservative government at
the last January election we will not
and cannot allow the labor party to
seize control of the order paper
they want to do so they should do
something they haven't done in 17 long
years and win a general election
the opposition now fully well that
members on this side who share their
legitimate concerns regarding fracking
cannot vote for their motion today
instead of and so instead of engineering
a constructive and fair debate on this
issue they have contrived to weaponize
this issue truly shameful behavior
however Madame Deputy speaker whilst I
do have the opportunity I would like to
State once again that the vast majority
of my constituents do not support
fracking returning to the foul Coast the
environmental and safety thresholds and
protections were breached when fracking
previously took place at the Preston New
Road sites only a few miles outside of
my constituency and as a result Kraken
stopped in 2019. now the war in Ukraine
has woken up the west and demonstrated
that we cannot rely on authoritarian
foreign regimes for our energy supplies
as such I do support the government in
striving to maximize more of our
domestic energy reserves in particular
North Sea oil and gas and nuclear power
and although I can see why the
government has put fracking back on the
table it should only take place when it
is safe and it is supported by local
communities something the government
have reiterated time and time again and
which the secretary of state has made
clear once again today that is a
position I wholeheartedly support I
welcome the steps the government are
taking to determine how local consent
can be established and I look forward
look Rebecca Long Bailey thank you madam
Deputy speaker fracking will not solve
the energy crisis indeed the Shale gas
extracted by fracking would make no
difference to gas prices and is a more
expensive alternative to Renewables
further [ __ ] would demonstrably
increase the risk of local Earth Tremors
as recently confirmed by the British
Geological Survey and on The Wider
environmental impact Greenpeace stay
that not only is [ __ ] bad for our
climate it risks causing air water and
noise pollution it uses toxic chemicals
that may not be regulated well enough an
accident could mean that these chemicals
leak Into Water Supplies or cause
pollution above ground in fact this has
happened many times in the U.S so why on
Earth with all of this in mind would the
government pursue a strategy that poses
such risks and flies in the face of
efforts to tackle climate change well
author and climate commentator Naomi
Klein calls it the shock Doctrine the
exploitation of wrenching crises to
smuggle through policies that Devour the
public sphere and further enrich a small
Elite but the Bandit capitalism extends
Beyond just fracking into the way the
government approaches our whole Energy
System the pursuit of markets are all
costs with little State intervention
keeps leading to the same problems
complex poorly designed mechanisms open
to gaming and profiteering that deliver
poor value for money if they deliver at
all and poor environmental outcomes and
when that system fails as it is doing
now well it's everybody else's problem
now there's a new generation calling for
change a green New Deal a green jobs
Revolution that would distribute custom
rewards progressively deepen economic
democracy and Kickstart an industrial
strategy to rebuild and light up Britain
on on this side of the house we get that
but I'm worried that we'll miss this
chance worse though I'm actually
frightened frightened that whilst there
are numerous colleagues on the bench's
opposite who may speak out against
fracking the fact remains that they are
still in the government led by an
environmental and economic Vandal and
although the clock May well be ticking
on the prime minister's days in office
as Naomi Klein sadly States when
powerful ideologies are challenged by
hard evidence from The Real World they
rarely die off completely a few True
Believers always remain to tell one
another that the problem wasn't the
ideal ideology it was the weakness of
the leaders who did not apply the rules
with sufficient rigor so that is why
today is so important that's why across
this house we have a moral duty to vote
in favor of this motion to introduce a
bin to bowel ban hydraulic backing for
Shale gas once and for all James Grundy
thank you madam Deputy speaker I was
very grateful that the Secretary of
State today confirmed that the dispatch
Box about a local veto and I think it's
very important as other colleagues have
said that that local veto on fracking
must be the Paramount one there can be
no local Authority overturning what has
been decided by local people in a
referendum or other similar independent
method of decision making because while
some colleagues today have spoken about
local authorities being bastions of
listening that is not always the case
with some local authorities
unfortunately some local authorities
would be cynically enough to pass
fracking applications in just a couple
of opposition-held wards and then they
would claim the planning committee was
the Democratic representative and so
what you would find is those three Wars
which were never going to vote for the
administration would be unable to hold
the administration of the council to
count
now I think it's very important that
local authorities aren't able to
Hornswoggle smaller communities within
the local Authority this way and that we
do by the mechanism that the secretary
of state is rightly set out and I look
forward to further detail on this enable
local residents to prevent local
authorities from trampling local rights
and I'm incredibly pleased that that has
been given because I do fear
unfortunately Madam Deputy speaker
the Wigan Council which is in a huge
dispute with local residents and is
fighting local residents to the teeth
over a number of incredibly unpopular
planning applications in just a handful
of areas within my constituency despite
the fact there have been thousands of
objections is fundamentally unwilling to
listen to objectors
I am delighted that with fracking that
would not be the case that the veto
would remain at the community level
and with that Madam Deputy speaker I
shall sit down I fear I have made my
point very clearly that the local Vice
must be the Paramount voice and if
people do not want it they should not
have it yeah
Margaret Greenwood thank you madam
Deputy speaker the government must span
fracking once and for all it's dangerous
outdated it's outdated dangerous and
expensive way to produce energy and it
will not provide the clean secure energy
that our country needs nor will it help
us meet our legally binding commitment
to Net Zero as friends of the Earth have
pointed out fracking risk contaminating
water it poses risk to Public Health and
the environment and is unlikely to
reduce energy bills the government's
written statement of November 2019 said
that the moratorium fracking would be
maintained until compelling new
evidences provided which addresses the
concerns around the prediction and
management of induced seismic seismicity
likewise the conservative party
Manifesto of 2019 on which members
opposites stood and were elected said we
will not support fracking unless the
science shows categorically that it can
be done safely nothing has changed and I
asked the minister to explain what he
thinks has the recent report by the
British Geological Survey found that
forecasting the occurrence of large
earthquakes and their expected magnitude
remains a significant challenge for the
geoscience community recently the
Secretary of State said that tolerating
a higher degree of risk and disturbance
appears to us to be in the National
interest so it appears that we have as
well as being Reckless with the economy
the government is being Reckless with
the environment and the health and
safety of our communities the committee
on climate change has made it clear that
moving away from fossil fuel consumption
will both benefit households as it will
reduce exposure to volleyball fossil
fuel prices and reduce
emissions the government speaks of
consent but um but it's a matter of very
real concern that there are reports that
households could be handed a thousand
pounds to consent to fracking in their
area Greenpeace has quite rightly
labeled this as a cynical Ploy and said
that the government must be hoping that
they can buy off people's concerns while
they're struggling with the cost of
living crisis there currently exists a
petroleum exploration and development
license
pedl184 covering an area of Northwest
England which includes my constituency
in rural West the license allows a
company need to pursue a range of oil
and gas exploration activities subject
to necessarily Drilling and development
consents and planning permission no
wonder my constituents are worried they
have made it abundantly clear that they
do not want to see fracking we on these
benches will stand up for our
constituents today and oppose fracking
the members opposite should stand by
their manifest festo commitment and do
the same
matters Madam Deputy speaker can I start
by with words from the conservative
party Manifesto page 55 because it's
very clear and it's there in black and
white we placed a moratorium on fracking
in England with immediate effect having
listened to local communities we have
ruled out changes to the planning system
we will not support fracking unless the
science shows categorically that it can
be done safely I read those words out
because they should mean something they
should mean something to all of those
opposite who were elected on those words
and if they don't mean anything to them
I'm sure they will mean something to the
people who voted them in here as well
and who will be watching very closely
how they vote today because the science
hasn't categorically show that it can be
done safely but I'd also want like to
thank the Tory whips actually for making
this a confidence vote in the Prime
Minister because after the week that she
has had I think that is more likely to
lead to Ventures voting Rivers than
against us but if they're not persuaded
by that please don't fall for the spin
that we've heard that we need to do
this to deal with the rising cost of
energy because it was not so long ago
that the now former Chancellor said that
those calling for the return of fracking
misunderstanded the situation
and he also said that if we lifted the
fracking moratorium it would take up to
a decade to extract sufficient volumes
and it would come at a high cost for
communities and our precious Countryside
no amount of shale gas from hundreds of
Wells dotted across rural England would
be enough to load the European price
anytime soon and with the best will in
the world private companies are not
going to sell the Shale gas they produce
the new hick consumers below the market
price they are not Charities after all
well even a stop clock is right twice a
day and it's so it's even the case sort
of discriminated form of Chancellor can
we write about something and he was
certainly right about that
I just finally modern Deputy speakers
say a few words about consently
dictionary definition of consent is
permission to do something or an
agreement to do something so let's be
clear that that is not the same as
getting a payment in lieu of consent and
it does not mean having a refined
planning process to create the illusion
of consent and I'm afraid the government
Amendment doesn't really take us to a
place where I am convinced that we will
have generally consent and whatever is
said from the dispatch box doesn't
really mean anything when cabinet
ministers are falling on a daily basis
because let's be clear consent is not
the same as consultation and this
amendment talks too much about
consultation rather than consent
consultation is not as robust it's not
as definitive and it's certainly not
what people would expect and the
business secretary said last month that
compensation and consent become two
sides of the same coin well I would say
that they cannot possibly be two sides
of the same coin compensation is payment
in recognition of a loss that doesn't
not in any way mean that people have
agreed to suffer that laugh loss and the
government really do want to get consent
for fracking the countryside they should
put it in their Manifesto and call the
general election and we'll see whether
they do get that concerns Christian
Whiteford thank you madam Deputy speaker
and please be called speaking Misty
Bates today which I believe the Whip's
opposite of called a confidence Motion
in the Prime Minister I don't know which
is more exciting for her to receive uh
her p45 is it outside or theirs which is
more excited uh the Prime Minister
promised but fracking will take place
only in areas with a clear public
consensus behind it but the business
secretary ruled out local referendums
and suggested that fracking companies
themselves could go around door to door
and ask people if they will consent
aside from this being a truly ridiculous
idea avoiding fracking operators as the
Arbiters the local concept would create
an obvious conflict of interest and
would undermine the authority of
democratically elected councils if the
business secretary is so Keen to start
getting talking about people's areas and
causing earthquakes I look forward to
the government's newer site opening in
Northeast Somerset in the coming weeks
it may surprise some but I agree with
many of the members opposite the member
for filed spoke passionately last week
and again today in regards to
constituents who were labeled as
loadouts by the business secretary when
I was a county councilor in Lancashire
when you know this was actually debated
over seven years ago and also now is the
member of Parma for Barry South I know
the people have ragged with Whitefield
and press which certainly aren't without
either and neither are the people of
lager yeah yeah I am a ghost fracking
Madam depth speaker it's unpopular it
industrializes the countryside and it
contributes to climate breakdown and
importantly fails to address the energy
crisis well it's not just me who thinks
that Madam Dev to speak it's for public
too you know uh one person said it would
take up to a decade to extract what we
need by fracking and that it was
pointless that was for Chancellor of
last week
it will create create enormous
disruption for little economic gain that
was for Chancellor of this week four
months ago the defense secretary post
proposals for a fracking site in his
constituency the Tory party chair cyber
defense secretary's letter opposing
fracking 11-up secretary said there
isn't strong support for fracking and I
agree the Secretary of State for dcms
didn't want it in her backyard and I
don't blame her so now we know that her
cabinet don't have faith in fracking or
her I look forward to many of the
members opposite joining me in the
lobbies today
Kerry McCarthy
thank you madam Deputy speaker today
we've heard from colleagues across the
house making clear their opposition to
fracking it was particularly powerful
hearing from MPS from the Lancashire
area which has already been affected by
the seismic shocks of previous Drilling
and their constituents live in fear of
that happening again fracking is
dangerous polluting and will not provide
energy security for this country and it
is deeply unpopular
the government finally seemed to get
that in 2019 with its Manifesto
commitment to a fracking ban and as it's
been said everyone on that side of the
house stood on that Manifesto and made
that promise to their constituents yet
it's only taken a matter of days for
this new Administration to bring frackin
back and not through a vote or a
consultation or a debate in this house
it was a decision taken just by the
Secretary of State alone who's not even
turned up to hear the winding up
speeches no scrutiny the Secretary of
State no scrutiny and no accountability
oh sorry I didn't see him there
um their Manifesto promised the ban on
fracking would remain in place until
evidence categorically proved it was
safe but the recent report from the
British Geological Survey commissioned
by the government has offered no new
evidence whatsoever to suggest the
situation has changed as The Honorable
member filed said the geology hasn't
changed how could it the science hasn't
changed Visa
so what did the secretary of state do
when he couldn't find the evidence he
wanted
he decided to change the rules on how
big an earthquake can be considered safe
I would laugh Madame Deputy speaker but
there's nothing funny about this
labor has been absolutely clear that we
will always oppose fracking whether in
opposition or in government and I'm
proud that the labor government in Wales
is keeping the ban
yeah
and let us not forget Madam Deputy
speaker that this Reckless decision
comes in the middle of a climate
emergency
at cop26 this government made a
commitment on the world stage to prior
to prioritize the clean energy
transition and end public support for
the fossil fuel sector by the end of
2022.
so how's that going a year on and then
not just bringing back fracking for gas
they're also issuing hundreds of new
licenses with fossil fuel extraction no
wonder the prime minister is trying to
wriggle out of attending cop in Egypt
next month
let's call this what it is it's climate
vandalism the decisions of this
government are undermining our climate
targets and trashing our reputation on
the global stage
as The Honorable member for West Ham
said it's taken a wrecking ball to years
of patient climate diplomacy and I'm
sure the cop president would have
something to say about that
the minister for climate change who's
replying to the debate today may be
willing to swallow his pride and to
claim that fracking is green in exchange
for a seat down the far end of the
cabinet table but
they're expensive they're polluting or
air and they're destroying our planet as
my right honorable friend to the member
for Doncaster North made clear earlier
the only solution to the energy crisis
is a green one
Deputy speaker removing a ban on
fracking shows that we cannot trust a
Tory promise even if it was embedded in
their Manifesto
so how can we trust what is being said
today about ensuring local consent and
let's be clear the amendment doesn't say
there will be a veto it doesn't explain
how that consent would be obtained and
it's very weak on the detail and it
doesn't promise a binding vote on this
house on what that consent would look
like
and as my right honorable friend the
member for Leeds Central said why do we
even need to do this we know that Poland
the government's own poll in shows that
only 17 of people support fracking and I
would imagine a large proportion of
those that will say but not in my
backyard were quite happy for it to I
think a Lord's Minister once said in the
desolate North that's where you would
frack
I'm sure that the government committing
to a ban on fracking today and
committing to Bringing forward their own
bill if they don't want labor to put the
um seize control of the order paper
would come as a great relief to many of
the government's own MPS our message to
colleagues on the opposite benches is
this
fracking is not necessary it is not
wanted and it is not inevitable
each of you there today on the
opposition benches have a chance to on
the opposite benches I should say have a
chance to yeah I'm a forward thinking on
my part each of you have a chance today
to ensure the voices of your
constituents are heard and that our
planet is protected
if you support our motion today we will
secure a binding vote on a bill to ban
fracking on the 29th of November in the
absence of any willingness from the
government to bring that forward itself
you will all have the opportunity to ban
fracking before a single drill starts up
in your constituencies
you know that's what your constituents
want you to do
you that's your only problem they know
that there's no excuse for doing it so
do the right thing and support the labor
motion today
oh yeah
Minister Graham Stewart thank you madam
Deputy speaker and it's a great pleasure
to wind up this debate which has had so
many excellent contributions from across
the house uh uh and it perhaps is not
for the first time that uh the right
honorable gentleman for Doncaster North
who is an extremely clever man who whom
I have a great deal of respect has been
a little bit too clever by half and
perhaps if more drafting had gone into
this instead of seizing the order paper
we could have had a different style an
attempt to seize the order paper because
quite clear quite clearly Madam Deputy
speaker this is not a confidence vote
but it is an attempt by her majesties it
is
obviously obviously obviously Madam
Deputy speaker this is not a confidence
race what it is
an attack what it is
uh order come on let's listen to the
minister and that means be quiet up
there as well that means to be quiet up
there as well order
Minister thank you madam Deputy speaker
but this is this uh attempt this attempt
I will give away uh the the
this this to the the right honorable
Madam Deputy speaker the right honorable
gentleman is getting over excited he
described himself he described himself
as a nerd and of course accurately
perhaps he should have spent more time
looking at parliamentary procedure uh
Madam Deputy speaker I
I'm proud to say that this government
has led the way in reducing emissions
and moving towards net zero the when
when the right honorable gentleman was
in power Madam Deputy speaker when he
left power in 2010 Not only was there
that note that said there was no money
left fewer than seven percent of our
electricity around 6.8 percent came from
Renewables it is this party on this side
of the house which has delivered the
Green Revolution will continue to
deliver the Green Revolution and means
that more than 40 percent Madam Deputy
speaker are they allowed to maintain
this ridiculous stuff it's bad enough
order order
Mr Davis we are having a debate if
everybody shouts at one another we can't
have a debate Minister thank you madam
Deputy speaker and it's it's brought
calm to the other side of the house to
point out that as I say electricity
seven percent when they left power more
than 40 percent today if you look at
Energy Efficiency and you look at people
struggling to heat their homes today
houses that were EPCC and above what was
the percentage The Honorable gentleman
wants to tell me from a sedentary
position what percentage was it when
labor left power I'll tell you it was 14
what is it today 46 it is this party
which is moving this country towards net
zero and not only doing it at home but
leading internationally as well but I'm
happy to give away tomorrow
I think the uh the minister for for
giving way he's absolutely right about
the Green Revolution which our region
and the Humber is playing such a big
part of but can I ask him to reflect on
the speeches of today because if this
was a clear vote on whether we have
fracking or not I would be in the
opposite lobby with the opposition uh I
will stick on any binding vote to my uh
Manifesto and election commitment to
oppose fracking absolutely so can it
reflect on that and can I urge him to
continue with the vein he was uh going
down which is how much we should be
investing in green energy
well I'm grateful to my own friend and
of course we are investing we have uh
near both of our constituencies seen the
transformation seen the transformation
if I may just at least answer this
without being permanently harassed by
the right honorable gentleman who should
learn to sit I can tell to my right
honorable friend he has seen the
transformation of the whole economics of
offshore wind he has seen this
government put in place the cfds which
are now being copied all around the way
Madam Deputy speaker I feel I feel if I
don't give away to the right honorable
gentleman he may suffer some serious
medical emergence
now Mr Speaker Madam Deputy speaker for
the guidance of the house the minister
said something very important from the
dispatch box he said this is not a
confidence motion and I think his
members will want to know that if he
confirms that then members opposite can
vote for our Motion in the safe
knowledge that they can be confident in
the current prime minister so can you
just confirm that well the right
honorable gentleman was so excited in
order to repeat something which I'd
already said multiple times colleagues
on this side of the house are perfectly
clear they are not going to surrender
and they're not going to allow the labor
party to be a government for a day by
seizing control of the order paper so
you know the
we we will we we will we will continue
we will continue point of order better
be a point of order I think it is man
definitely speak it's really important
that members know what they are voting
on
members know what they're voting on
minister
thank you madam Deputy speaker we will
continue to lead the world and drive
forward offshore an onshore wind solar
energy and uh we will do smrs and Giga
what level nuclear as well as support
for amr's and we will come forward we
will come forward Madam Deputy speaker
with proposals to support hydrogen and
CC us we are looking all across the
piece to drive the Green Revolution but
as part of that Madam Deputy speaker as
as part as part of that work we also
need to ensure the gas and oil that we
rely on at the moment as we manage and
drive down our usage on the path to Net
Zero um
[Music]
I really do need to press him on this
issue of a confidence vote because many
of us have been told today by our whips
that if we vote or abstain from voting
against this motion we will lose the
whip so could he please confirm whether
that is the case
[Music]
[Applause]
we have to hear the answer Minister I I
Thank The Honorable lady uh for that
question and that is a part A matter for
party managers and I'm not a party
manager um foreign
[Applause]
Deputy speaker Community Support is so
important and that is why we have uh as
as we've heard from the Secretary of
State today pledge to colleagues to
ensure that that Community Support there
will be that Community veto that we've
heard so much about from colleagues from
East Sussex North Dorset bognor Regis
and littlehampton Southwest bedfordshire
Taunton Dean Winchester East Yorkshire
my neighbor Gloucester bolsover
Scarborough and Whitby up the coast from
me South thanat Worcester Gloucester
Rother Valley North Dorset Ashfield
rushcliff Blackpool South and Lee and I
will it's interesting to see the liberal
Democrat on his feet who in his speech
Madam Deputy speaker suggested not in
drop more of gas or oil should come out
of the ground forgetting that 75 of our
energy needs today come from fossil
fuels it is this government which is
leading the green transformation Nation
to take us away from it it is this
government which is driving forward Net
Zero not only here but equally
importantly all around the world and it
is of course my colleague who has been
president president of cop 26 who has
moved this the world from having just 30
percent 30 percent of global GDP covered
by Net Zero pledges 30 in 2019 to more
than 90 percent today it is that
transformation of the global position on
the pathway to Net Zero that has been a
critical path as well as leading the
development of of Net Zero at home that
is why we will continue to make sure
that we develop and that's why we are
issuing licenses or issuing
um uh uh blocks in the North Sea so that
we can produce domestic oil and gas as
we manage as we manage that pathway down
we will manage it down
you know the question is that the
question be now purchase man is that
opinion say I
I of the country no I think the eyes
have it the eyes have it the question is
that the original words stand part of
the question as marriage that opinion
say I I of the contrary no
[Applause]
clear the lobby
order
the question is that the original words
stand part of the question as a matter
is that opinion say I I of the contrary
no no
tell us for the eyes Lily and Greenwood
and Jessica Morden tell us where the
nose Amanda soloway and Mark jenkinson
foreign
I discovered
foreign
[Applause]
thank you
[Music]
here
[Music]
characters
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
[Music]
everything
foreign
foreign
[Music]
thank you
yourself
thank you
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
[Music]
foreign
foreign
thank you
foreign
foreign
foreign
thank you
order coming Sergeant please for the
sergeant please investigate the delay in
the no Lobby
[Applause]
foreign
foreign
questions
order
eyes to the right 230 the nose to the
left
326.
[Music]
thank you
the eyes to the right
230 the nose to the left
326 so the nose habit the nose have it
unlock oh point point of water Tang him
Debonair thank you madam Deputy speaker
I'm I wish to on a point of order
um there are rumors very strong rumors
that the government Chief whip has
apparently resigned I wonder if it's
possible to get some clarity more than
rumors more than at work you want to say
no
I seek your guidance on whether or not
this can be confirmed given that this is
actually a matter of parliamentary
discipline
The Honorable lady raises a point as to
whether a member of the government has
resigned I have not been given any such
information I know no more than that and
it's not a point of order for the chair
point of order Mr farron thank you madam
Deputy speaker I wonder if you could
clarify
that during the debate we just had the
minister from the dispatch box closing
the debate informed his colleagues that
this was not a vote of confidence yet we
saw earlier in writing from the
government deputy chief with that it was
could it be possible that members
opposite voted in the division just now
without without any clarity as to what
it was they were actually voting for
I Thank The Honorable gentleman for his
point which is of course not a point of
order for the chair
um my concern is that what what it says
in the order paper is correct and
accurate and it is and I thank the
honorable gentleman for the point he
raises but it's not one on which I can
judge uh ministers are responsible for
their own words
is it a point of order point of order Mr
Bryant
[Applause]
and Deputy speaker I
I would urge you to launch an
investigation into the scenes outside
the entrance to the no Lobby earlier as
you know members are expected to be able
to vote without fear or favor and the
behavior code which is agreed by the
whole of the house says that there shall
never be bullying or harassment of
members I thought
I saw members
being physically manhandled into another
Lobby
and being bullied
if we want to stand up against
in this house of our staff we have to
stop bullying in this chamber as well
don't we
oh no oh no we're talking about Behavior
we will have a little bit of good
behavior for a moment on both sides of
the house
yes
The Honorable gentleman raises an
important matter about behavior and he
knows better than anyone else that we
have an extremely good system for it for
investigating allegations of bullying
intimidation or bad behavior and if the
honorable gentleman cares to bring
evidence and facts to me I will make
sure that the matter is properly
investigated of course we must have
decorous Behavior at all times and so we
will now proceed quietly and politely
the question is that the proposed words
be there added as many as of that
opinion say I I of the contrary no no
I think the eyes have it the eyes have
it
um the question is the main motion as
amended as a matter of that opinion say
I
of the contrary no I think the eyes have
it the eyes have it
thanks
that concludes that item of business and
we now come to motion 3 relating to
business of the house supplementary
estimates and supply enough
appropriation adjustments built minister
to move
the question is As on the order paper as
long as that opinion say I I of the
contrary no I think the eyes have it the
eyes have it motion number four on
sanctions minister to move
but the question is As on the